because facebook isn't creepy enough
apparently people have been getting
messages asking them
are you concerned that someone you know
is becoming an extremist get support
there's also messages that say things
like kevin you may have been exposed to
harmful extremist content recently and
they're warning people that
nefarious actors are trying to
manipulate you to manipulate your anger
and your rage
and you must click the get support
button because only mark zuckerberg
knows how to make you feel better
well we're going to talk a whole lot
about censorship
extremism and where that's bringing us
because
well that's all we really can talk about
these days because of the censorship you
see
joining us today is a a a
scientist phd pathologist dr chris
martinson
hi you are a an expert on
on many things scientific including uh
vaccines and
you know testing laboratory work and
medications that's that's fair to say
correct yeah i've spent a lot of time in
and around labs test tubes
pipettes so the question everyone
everyone is dying to know
you know the ques the these very very
important questions what do you like
most about joe biden
uh mostly every time they trot him out i
just i can only think elder abuse
i like his uh his his strength and his
zeal and his
his is a patriotic fervor yes truly
one of the greatest presidents of all
time and uh a bit aside
there's a lot that we're going to talk
about in the in the in the members
podcast at timcast.com
and it's really serious stuff you you're
you got a phd
i mean but they don't that doesn't
matter i mean people in the chat already
when they saw that your name was in the
title they're like all right this is
banned
yeah so we're going to be very very
careful we're going to have a nice fun
family-friendly critique of censorship
and
these big tech companies and dr fauci
and
uh and then over at timcast.com we'll
get real real serious with what we can
so
you know bear with us we'll have some
fun for this next couple of hours as we
normally do and then we're gonna you
know
have a lightning in a bottle for
teamcast.com but uh thanks for thanks
for coming
thanks and thanks good to be here and um
this is a little bit i am
kind of toxic you know so my first video
out to the world
about coronavirus was january 23rd 2020
by february 5th my wiki page which had
been up for 12 years got yanked
they deleted it they deleted it 12 years
you had a wikipedia
you're this uh phd pathologist you've
got you've got a youtube channel
as well lots of followers yep not
notable anymore though
i was a non-notable person according to
wikipedia they said well this guy yeah
he was a scientist but what has he done
lately and of course this is some editor
who maybe graduated high school maybe
not we don't know right it's just some
anonymous person claiming that i don't
have scientific red because they said so
but yeah that was that was just within
less than three weeks after i said hey
there's this thing coming out of china
because remember
let's rewind that was back when the
media was all like it's just the flu bro
right and youtube actually censored me
for even bringing it up
it's really weird how this thing has
progressed especially without your [ __ ]
but we'll get into this we'll start with
this first story so thanks for being
here we got ian chilling thank you tim
yeah man
ian crossland up in the house chris
awesome to see you again man and
you have a lot of experience with like
regenerative farming i don't know do you
have like hands-on
experience with farming and stuff well i
have a farm so i'm practicing i'm bad at
it but i'm getting better what's your
farm
like well we got three cows we got about
30 chickens uh we're getting a couple of
pigs when i get back this week
um so you you would say you have a
veritable chicken city
yes we have little baby chickens because
we've got the rooster don't get the
rooster
okay we got a roaster he's been
screaming his mouth just makes noise you
know what's funny is
every time i walk up he looks at me and
then he mounts one of the chickens
because i think that's a power move it
is no yeah i think it actually is
because he only does it when i go up
there and they know that i'm the one who
goes in and i'm the boss and i'm the one
always you know shoots him out of the
way and
so he's like hey yo look at me i like
jumps on a chicken
you've raised those chickens as well
because they're real nice to me now if i
go if i get near them they come up to me
and they're really excited to see me
well we'll we'll we'll talk about uh
chickens and farming and serious ship
we got lydia as well politics of chicken
city not withstanding i'm also here
these chickens are very cute and
enjoyable they're com
they'll come up and try to pop you with
their beak but we should probably get to
like talk about stuff
all right enough chickens here's what
you got to do my friends you got to go
to timcast.com and become a member
because
i think you know ian mentioned what
someone hit you up and they were like
can you just do
an hour less of the main show and an
hour more of the bonus show where we get
real
dark i would love to i love just letting
loose man
we can we i think i think there may come
a time where we have to consider like
some episodes like something like this
we might have to reduce the amount of
time
for this instance we'll just keep it
like we normally do but um
i mean i was thinking about this before
we even got started with the show i'm
like going off the checklist things i'm
like we'll get banned for that we'll get
banned for that we'll get banned for
that we'll get banned for that why are
we even doing a show on this platform
well there's a lot of people who we need
to like let them know where to find
these conversations so it's like if we
just stop going on youtube a lot of
people would be confused and lost
one of the things that really helped we
started changing the name of the the
members only podcasts
and all of a sudden everyone's like i
can find it now it was so hard for me to
find
and so i'm just i'm trying to balance
that we have
you know we get we get hundreds of
thousands of people who watch these
episodes every night
and how do i inform every single person
i could go on twitter i could tweet
people don't see it so we'll do the show
to the best of our abilities but we can
talk about a lot we can talk about
censorship we can talk about comments
made by fauci why we don't like the guy
and then we can talk about scientific
expertise and a lot of the stuff that
youtube doesn't allow us to over at
timcast.com so
again i will also add check the alpha
for the new site oh yeah everyone's
morale just like went through the roof
it looks amazing we're super excited
we are going to be launching the
mysteries podcast soon
which is uh excellent shane has another
article up uh
right now actually let me see if i can i
can i can pull it up right here
uh there we go shane cashman the
pentagon sees a balloon so this is a
this is a long story talking about
saucers ufos
and breaking things down it's it's
really really incredible stuff so you
wanna take this out and that's gonna be
part of a new podcast as well so
that being said let's talk about how
these creepy jerks are making it
difficult for us to have real
conversations
pcmag.com says facebook prods
users who've been exposed to extremist
content to get
help this is where it's get it's getting
weird it's getting real
it's getting weird look at this are you
concerned that someone you know is
becoming an extremist
we care about preventing extremism on
facebook others
in your situation have received
confidential support the other one says
kevin
you may have been exposed to harmful
extremist content recently
violent groups tried to manipulate your
anger and disappointment
you can take action now to protect
yourself and others
all right you can take action everybody
listens you can take action right now
you can smash the like button subscribe
and share this video
that way um people can get a
non-corporate opinion on why this is
creepy and freaky just think about that
that would be a peaceful action though
of course right
very very peaceful pressing that like
button peaceful smashing yeah that's the
big conundrum about these these networks
everyone's like
why don't you get off youtube and it's
like bro we upload to rumble now we're
uploading to rumble
now that it's perfect we've always
uploaded uh have we i don't think irl's
on mines but my personal account is
always been
kind of always been on those irrelevant
minds yeah we we want to and we want to
make sure we're leveraging the networks
as they exist in the best of our
abilities
so we can keep the network alive think
of it this way
the way i said it before is like do you
retreat from a battlefield where you're
still
holding some ground just because you're
like that battlefield is completely open
it's like not necessarily hold the
ground you can
and so there's a lot of things we can't
talk about and it's getting worse
i'm texting some of these other big
podcast people right now and i'm like yo
what's going on like there's breaking
news we can't talk about it
like i had to i emailed google and i'm
like hey look at this story and they're
like well you know
and i'm all right can't say these things
that's insane
that's how bad and broken this is i've
noticed i think our presence here is
helping
guide the uh the youtube behavior and
like terms a little bit because i
noticed they relax their swearing
uh measurements and they're like you
know what go for it if you want to cuss
feel free
because it's like it's just so
entertaining and if we if we start
cussing it's hilarious
and they know that and they want it to
be hilarious i don't think that's us
sure it is i think so but let's let's
crazy let's talk about this facebook
thing because i want to
look at this they say confidential
support who do you think
at facebook is going to be the person
that will reach out to you and you're
like help help i've seen a post from ben
shapiro oh no
like a psychiatrist that they hire it's
gonna be some woke 20 year old
yeah or i mean to be honest it's going
to be like some 20 year old college
student from india
yeah no joke i mean outsourcing uh call
center stuff
you're gonna get someone who's you know
probably got a checklist of like
do you feel like you are sad and
depressed no
okay right did ben shapiro touch you in
any way
you said exposed i was thinking i don't
know is this about my uncle or what is
this about you know what's going on here
these social networks have like huge um
psychology
departments to take care of their admins
because the admins see such vile and
vicious things as they're going through
like making sure like
blown off arms or like a horrific stuff
so
i wonder if they're using those same
therapists to help now
but i don't know it's kind of vague i
mean
i don't know what they expect to get out
of this other than creeping people out
but i want to show you this meme from
kerry wedler it says are you concerned
that someone you know is becoming an
extremist we care about preventing
extremism on facebook
others in your situation have received
confidential support and then of course
there's obi-wan kenobi says well of
course i know him
he's me yes we've all been exposed to
this content but define extremists
sure well a biological dissident yeah
when i first saw this i thought for sure
that it was about black lives matter and
antifa but of course
i was not correct of course they're only
talking about the right-wing extremism
that they say is the biggest threat
obviously it should be blm and antifa
but it's not and i feel like this is a
flex
from facebook they're just like oh we're
just gonna show them what we can do
we're watching you we can see what
you're looking at we can see what you're
liking
it's creepy it's absolutely creepy of
course and
the it's kind of like that old
definition of you know what's porn and
the supreme court just said well i know
it when i see it right yeah it's
gonna be one of these things right we
can't operate that way no we can't like
you need to be able to define what
you're talking about
right so so i've been searching my brain
i'm like thinking when was the last time
in history it was awesome when
censorship showed up
like like when did that work out real
well was that the nazi book burnings so
the us office of censorship when did so
world war ii loose lips sink ships yeah
but you know if you're talking about
opsec that might be just a little bit
different from saying i'm going to talk
about a scientific paper which somebody
approves of right it's a very different
very different beast so what i find
interesting in this is that all remember
i have this i'm cursed with this memory
i can remember all the way back to the
last election
right remember what the there was all
this concern like nazis nazis nazis they
were everywhere right so what are nazis
famous for well i think they're really
famous for marginalizing and
you know shutting things down well
that's exactly the environment i feel
like i'm living in right now so
of course i've had people call me up and
say chris you don't understand
this is exactly like what it was like
when i was in cuba right when the whole
revolution was going down this is what
it was like
old this older guy you know during the
soviet times right have you have you
heard about the the the parents of
loudoun county no was it was it loudoun
county where that woman said it's
just like the culture evolution chinese
mother the struggle sessions yeah
is that where we are yeah yeah i mean
it's it's shocking that uh
you know there was there was something i
wanted to ask you about
you know you were talking about vaccines
you're talking about efficacy you're
talking about medical treatments what's
your favorite color
blue blue excellent wow ian green green
okay thanks youtube
it's been a blast this is the kind of
content you want on your platform hahaha
swear word i just learned that
[Laughter]
that green is in the middle of the human
vision spectrum
so it made me think that maybe we
developed the ability to see green
first and maybe that's because trees and
grass are green
magnesium and chlorophyll is green so we
just evolved to see
that was the first color we started to
notice dude i i i i am fairly optimistic
i have to be i have to be honest i was i
was
you know getting pretty pessimistic for
a while and then
um you know michael mouse was a constant
influence on this show is very
optimistic because he's always mocking
and laughing at these people
now i do get some concern when he says
things like you know look how dumb these
people are
how could you possibly be worried about
losing the culture or something that
effect
and i'm like yeah zombies are dumb too
but sometimes the zombies take over they
never stop
yeah like and they turn other people
into zombies
so true when you see that when you see
the zombie like
head butting into a door and like just
bouncing and they're like look how dumb
it is
and then ten thousand of them are
marching towards you you do get scared
but uh but i am optimistic for a lot of
reasons mate as i've been saying
recently the night is always darkest
before the dawn
maybe it's bad right now but look at uh
the stuff we've been able to do over it
over at tmcs.com we we've we've hired a
couple more writers we've got a new
editor coming on we got some we got
new podcasts i am confident that youtube
will be
forced by the market to stop doing what
they're doing
or i i i'll say this i really don't
think it's going to be republicans
they're going to they're going to be
like wagging their finger for the next
five years nothing's going to happen
but uh i i should say i don't believe
100
that the market is going to force you to
change but uh look at joe rogan
yeah joe rogan left youtube um for the
most part
took a deal with spotify and he was able
to host
brett weinstein and uh who's the other
guy pierre cory yeah
and we can't repeat what they said on
that show but it is a great show and i
highly recommend everyone
everyone watch that show and the new
york times
wrote a pseudo hit piece on joe recently
mentioning the conversations they're
having
now i'm not entirely convinced spotify
is happy
with the conversations they're happening
having but
he's got a deal and they can't just ban
him so it allows
it's like it's like joe got himself
locked into place on a platform that
probably would have banned him if he did
it independently
if joe well joe being joe they probably
would have loved it if he just went to
spotify
but if uh for a channel like this
if we did the same show as joe off of
youtube spotify would probably ban it
they had they had all those employees at
spotify trying to get joe banned
but he's got this deal where he's like
locked into place he's got 11 million
listeners
yeah you know what are they going to do
he's got more listeners than most
nearly all of mainstream media so he's
got power
is that the metric that's come out 11
million listeners i think that's the
last one i heard because
that's that those he has he has like 10
10 million subscribers on youtube was
like 11 million subscribers
i'm wondering how many people still
listen to him on spotify though
i don't anymore yeah i i haven't no no
disrespect like joe's rad can send him a
friend
i haven't checked out i haven't been
able to see one of his shows there was
one instance where a show came up and i
like tried pulling up spotify to figure
it out and i just like i give up you
know what i mean yeah there's a little
barrier of entry i used to just pull the
thing on youtube with no problem
and i would have it like playing to my
left while i'm like reading news and
stuff and i just listen for a couple
hours
you know it's harder when i i have so
much respect for brett weinstein and so
i
i will go the distance for him and joe
of of course but it really because i was
like you i didn't get spotify i wouldn't
get it i was like f this but
when you see these people i mean he's
friends with some of the most
influential and amazing humans on earth
so i'm going i'm going for that and
spotify knows it their valuation after
they paid
joe whatever it was 100 million or
whatever is up like billions billions of
dollars no and i regretted not buying
any of that stock because i'm pretty
sure like a bunch of people
knew that it was happening and then like
i didn't even think about it
and then instantly as soon as they
announced it in the press like
skyrocketed i'm like
weren't people talking about that behind
the scenes like didn't someone tell me
something about that i got to pay
attention more to this stuff
i don't think that's insider trading
though i have nothing to do with the
business someone just mentioned hey i
think this thing's going to happen i'm
like
oh i don't care all right dark is before
the dawn though i got to tell you i know
a lot of people have been
canceled and censored just in the past
two weeks it's getting worse big stuff
right so
so this woman um who works for the flccc
joyce
she writes this this really big article
called the flccc oh sorry that's the
frontline covid critical care document
that's dr p corey so my first youtube
strike happened when
um i was reviewing his testimony so he
was in front of the senate had like
eight million views i thought this is
safe so i took his
thing i pulled three clips just reacted
to the three clips saying hey you should
listen to what he's saying here it makes
sense
that was my first strike they gave you a
strike that was recently they took down
this guy's senate testimony
they did that too but they gave me the
strike for reviewing the testimony right
i wonder if they're gonna get mad at us
for mentioning the testimony
at all i wouldn't be surprised i don't
think so they might get mad
but i don't it doesn't violate any terms
to talk about
as far as i know to reference it bro uh
crowder got a strike for mentioning cdc
data
it's it's they don't care man they're
carpet bombing channels yes
and so people are like tim why do you
keep saying talk to your doctor so much
first and foremost
i genuinely believe a private doctor
knows more
than than rogan fauci or anybody on tv
but also it's like
when we do when we do segments for this
show
we do a two-hour podcast of course in
the context of the live show
i'll say something like it is my genuine
opinion that
you know your medical history to a
private doctor like your personal doctor
he's gonna know what's better for you
than anybody on tv or whatever
but then when we do another segment
because we break them up
that context has to be in it as well
otherwise we'll get banned i'm not
exaggerating people like
so if we if we talk for 10 minutes and
at the beginning of it i say make sure
you go to your doctor
we make a clip where we're like here's
what dr chris martinson was saying
and it has to be included youtube
specifically told me that
and then if we make another 10 50 minute
segment we're talking about something
else
and as soon as it comes up i have to say
it otherwise we get banned
okay well it's good information too it's
not just hyperbole it's not just it's
not just a show of faith i mean you
really do want to talk to your personal
doctor
about your personal medical business i
know it is
this is what candice owens was saying
was like why are people so dumb that
they're gonna like listen to a comedian
and then take that as medical advice
people need to have some responsibility
for their actions
that's a really good point like the
media gets mad at joe rogan for having
an opinion on vaccines and it's like
yeah we do it it says a lot
about our society that
maybe it is more about youtube and their
faith and humanity
versus humanity in general like if
someone did
a podcast where they said i'm not gonna
make a hypothetical because youtube
would mad at me but if they did if they
if someone said something like you know
ride your bicycle backwards it's fun
and then a bunch of people just went and
did it and got hurt youtube genuinely
believes people will watch peeves and
like they genuinely believe people watch
youtube channels and then just instantly
be like i'm gonna do everything they
just did
like without thinking about it they all
they jumped off a bridge
well isn't that true isn't that kind of
the divide so i trust the people who
follow me to be intelligent and take
responsibility and they do
i trust them youtube has this other sort
of patrician attitude which is
listen we know we can handle this
information
but we're worried about other people
right so it's this very sort of looking
down that
they believe that all these other people
are going to do really dumb stuff so
remember
way back when there was this whole thing
and i cannot even know if i can say the
word but but this woman gave this
this guy died from this fish tank
cleaner and they used it and used it and
used it and used it and then his buddies
wrote and said by the way
bruce was a really careful guy he was an
engineer he
never would have spooned stuff in and by
the way his wife was new and she was a
complete raging
you know [ __ ] and so they were a little
worried
that maybe something had happened
because you know guys tend to
if they're gonna off their partners they
do it violently and women choose poison
so it's very old story and so
there's a real story there that that
somebody could look at and the media
just ran with it over and over and over
again
that that's the danger this one case
that what happened
and much more complicated than it's been
presented yeah
if if trump says something it's got to
be wrong and bad
there's something funny happening
recently trump goes to the border right
and uh kamala harris won't go to the
border she won't deal with immigration
trump announces he's going to go there
and he did and he had a press conference
with greg abbott
and of course then kamal immediately is
like okay i'm going i'm going i'm going
apparently she went to the wrong place
like she went to somewhere that wasn't
relevant necessarily 100 miles away yeah
but
close i i yeah i noticed uh someone
someone noticed this on twitter they
said
i think it was politico put out trump's
having a very very bad day
they mentioned like i think the cfo from
trump organization was indicted on like
not paying taxes on benefits which is
the weirdest thing
like yeah but like th this is such a
slap on the wrist level offense usually
they're just like hey you owe us a
million dollars and they go okay here's
your million dollars have a nice day
actually indicted the guy for not paying
taxes on his benefits and so anyway
you see this email come out saying trump
is having a really bad day
and it's like they're just lying in wait
to say if trump does
anything we need to shut down that
conversation
before it could happen so trump
supporters are watching right
it's a bit we have this reoccurring
conversation with leaders and followers
and who's what and and the the danger of
too many leaders you know
but what i'm interested to hear what you
think about like just the nature of
humanity that that we sort of segment
into this
one leader and a bunch of followers and
society it's almost now that society
thinks that they've just like this is
how it's going to be there's a bunch of
people that are followers by nature
you can't change it it's human nature so
we have to protect against that you know
we've got these people at the top or
whatever that are
supposedly like trying to build a world
around that
concept and i what do you think about
that
well if listen i'd be all for i would
love to be able to relax into the idea
that you have a good competent leader
out there right but i don't i really
honestly think our leadership right now
is taking us in a direction
this horrifying every dimension i look
at this right so the federal reserve is
now printed
it has a balance sheet that's eight
trillion dollars
look at the price for cold rolled steel
look at the price i mean do we just have
inflation raging
and all they can think to do is their
precious stock market they're going to
keep throwing money and it's the dumbest
thing ever
right and that's the leadership we have
on the economic side
but i got to tell you again still i look
at what's happening ecologically around
here in terms of species loss
particularly at the bottom of the food
chain one does not willingly lose the
bottom of the food chain we're losing
insects
because we're losing insects we're
losing the birds and you know it's going
to be one of those things where you
can't quite predict what's going to
happen people like oh you know you lose
a few honeybees we get some honeybees
but
eventually you lose one too many species
and then the next thing you know you
have this mysterious brown mold going
across your crops you don't know what's
happening because there's something too
complicated to understand
so we need our leadership is taking us
down the wrong direction but they have
one
unifying thing if you can make money at
it it's an okay thing
right regarding the bees we talked a
little bit about the bees
dying and colony collapse disorder and
that it's linked to neonicotinoid
pesticides those things are the worst i
i wrote about those in 2015
right it was completely obvious what had
happened back then this is
everybody heard about maybe ddt and
silent spring rachel carson traced his
book we said oh never again we learned
our lesson we didn't
we've created a worse thing with the
neonicotinoids first off they don't just
target your insect species you want
they're a biocide not an insecticide
a single cro coating on a kernel
kill a bird second thing is it has a
thousand life half day so you're a
farmer you spray it on your field
a thousand days later half of it's still
there but you know you farm every year
so you spray a little more in 365 days
and it's just now accumulating
to the point i was standing under an
apple tree in i live in rural western
massachusetts we live next to the
largest contiguous
wilderness area left in massachusetts
four square miles it's beautiful
and we had no bees no bees this spring
no little ones no big ones no bumble
bees no honey bees nothing
i went outside earlier um we got a bunch
of blackberry bushes everywhere
and and they're called wine berries i
thought they were raspberries but i
guess they're wine berries there's like
an east asian variant which is invasive
whatever
and uh they're delicious they're
everywhere but i went outside and we got
the little white flowers growing
everywhere there was like a thousand
bees
like bumble bees now when i grow up i
was always like freaked out because i'm
allergic
but it's it's yellow jackets you're
worried about i walked through a field
of flowers and the bees and the bees
were chilling like
they don't care yeah they're chill just
don't step on them they're totally happy
they're good people you know they are
they're very good they did their thing i
did my thing they're helping make the
berries come in and everything and uh
oh i found some pawpaw too i'm really
excited did you eat that's cool no
they're not ready yet
they're tiny but it's gonna be really
great we're really excited for this uh
but anyway back to the more serious
topic
there we go i've i've talked about
leadership yeah i've talked
you last time you were on the show you
mentioned that like uh
not just colony collapse disorder but
like insect populations in general have
the general decline
and it's interesting when i talk to uh
people who are in the more political
space
like you're a scientist you know i talk
to people in the political space and
they're like oh all this climate change
stuff
all this overpopulation stuff it's not
true it's it's political
and i'm like oh we had this guy on was
talking about like
you're i think you mentioned last time
like ocean dead zones too or did i i
might have
i may have brought that up but yeah like
what's your what's what's your opinion
on what's going on with with the insect
populations collapsing with uh with that
stuff
and we're we're we're deviating a little
bit but we'll we'll rope things back but
i really want to hear your thoughts on
this
well thanks because this is really this
is the core of what i what i do in the
world is i'm trying to talk about that
we're
at a very unusual time in human history
not us history not chinese history not
indian history you just human and we're
at a point now where there isn't a spare
continent
like there isn't an extra place to go
right even the you know the wf crowd the
davos crowd they have the great reset
and they they open with one of their
slides they say by 2050 we're going to
need three planets of resources but we
only have one what we can do
right so it's actually a major driver of
politics
finance you know futures hope stream so
it's a big deal
but i like to drive things down to
little anecdotes so that makes it makes
it easier to understand so i'm reading
these papers these scientists have said
hey all the salmon smelt are are
swimming upside down and falling and
dying
it's not cool because you're trying to
save the salmon right and they look into
it and they find out that the salmon are
missing
thiamin which is a b vitamin just it's
missing so then they go scouring all
over the world and it's missing from the
whole it's missing from the oceans
everywhere whoa so how did we
humans how did we how did we how do you
mess up the thiamin
cycle right it's crazy i mean look it's
like there's all these science articles
about it
that one thing alone like we've we've
done something
that has damaged the ocean so severely
that the fish
can't reproduce which means the birds
can't eat so bird oceanic bird
population is down 70
right you push that to a point we live
in a complex
ecological web and we don't know this is
the dread you don't know when that one
thread snaps and now it clicks into a
new
state of being which we might not like
we might not find it so awesome we don't
know but we should have a little
humility and
back up a tiny bit so so you're
basically saying that a lot of this
stuff's true i mean we've got uh
you know colony what's it called colony
collapse disorder with the bees and and
we need pollinators badly and i
you when you when you have a farm a
garden or you've even got like wild
fruits and vegetables growing you really
understand the importance of pollinators
so uh i mentioned pawpaw for instance
this is they call it hillbilly banana
and it looks delicious i think i've had
it before a long time ago it is very
difficult to produce
because you need two genetically
distinct pawpaw trees
very close to each other and beetles
have to pollinate like
beetles and flies so apparently people
hang roadkill near the trees hoping that
the flies will pollinate
it's so crazy how some some things are
difficult now
that balance can get disrupted but here
here's what i
to rope all these things back together
you mentioned censorship we talked a lot
about that you've been censored
but then you're also saying things that
probably support
a lot of these like un agenda things
like agenda 21 for a sustainable
development or
agenda 2030 which is the sustainable
development goals we talked about that
yesterday
it sounds kind of like you're in a way
similar to rorschach from watchmen
are you familiar so uh
basically the the the bad guy ozzy
mendias
simulates an alien invasion so that it
ends the cold war because the u.s and
soviet union are about to blow each
other up
by simulating an alien simulating the
alien invasion it stops
the war from happening they unify
against this perceived alien threat
so he lies to the people of the world to
stop them from
this war he is he's a smart guy but
dr manhattan and all the heroes they
find out what he's doing doctor
manhattan of course is the only guy with
their superpowers rorschach
is a moral absolutist so even though he
understands what the bad guy did
actually saving the world with his evil
plan killing millions of people
he says i'm still gonna tell everyone
ever anyway what's happening
and so i guess what i'm saying is you
know last time you're on the show you
mention these things a lot of people
you know in the political space don't
know about or disagree with
and you're actually making a case for
why we need to curtail
a lot of what's going on with uh fossil
fuels and
and human mass production of
petrochemicals and things like that
but then you're also coming out and
telling everybody the the truth about
certain studies things we can't mention
right now but we will mention at
timcast.com
can't wait because it's like you're
aware of what's going on and uh i guess
i'll put it simply it sounds like you're
more dedicated to the truth
you know well well i am and and you know
i like to add one plus one today and get
two
and i'd like that to happen tomorrow as
well yeah i like consistency
but you you know two plus two is five
now so well that's the problem
right and that's that's um a derivative
of how many genders we have which is
i think you're right yeah yeah right
well so so
i know these are difficult subjects and
all that and and um
but it does speak to this idea that
we're at a critical crossroads and the
only way i can think to get through it
is by being
honest unflinchingly honest with
ourselves
and being able to talk about things no
matter how uncomfortable so this whole
this censorship is coming at a bad time
because it's saying we won't allow you
to talk about stuff if it's gonna like
pinch pharma profits
or whatever the story is right or their
global agenda or their global agenda
these so so in part of my work i get to
hang out with a lot of these
very very rich people and i hate to tell
you this they're just people
yeah right they're not that much smarter
they think they are
but they're actually not right so um
this thing that we're in right now is a
complex world here's the thing about
complex
systems they have emergent behaviors
meaning you can't predict what they're
going to do you just can't
so they're going to have these wonderful
plans and they're going to try and like
control everything and they think they
can
control all of this down but i think
that's what got us into this trouble in
the first place we tried to control
everything
monsanto syngenta they had a better
pesticide let's just see if we can
get this right and you do that and then
nature says oh no that was a bad idea
are you familiar with frederick bastiat
uh i'm not super familiar with him but i
just saw him
who is he real quick uh what maybe 1700s
or so
um he was a uh an economist and a
philosopher
of sorts he has a great quote if the
natural tendencies of mankind are so bad
that it is not safe to permit people to
be free how is it that the tendencies of
these organizers are always good
do not the legislators and their
appointed agents also belong to the
human race
or do they believe that they themselves
are made of a finer clay than the rest
of mankind
hmm these world improvers you got to
watch out for them that that that
quote right there is the perfect summary
of things i've been saying about why i
don't trust the authoritarianism when
bill gates gets up on that ted stage
and he's like you know we've got 6.4
billion people on the planet
and we're looking at 9 billion in the
next 10 years with vaccines and
and reproductive health services and
health care we can lower that by maybe
10 to 15
this becomes like a wild conspiracy
theory where they're saying he wants to
depopulate
what he's actually saying is population
management to end poverty
that that's the reuters fact check
official statement and i'm just like
bill gates is not a super genius with a
giant pulsating brain that makes him
levitate and fly through the air
he's a guy but he's a guy who figured
out how to collect resources
that does not mean he knows how to
manage the world in fact i would bet a
large sum of money
it it's actually a good example of why
he can't manage the world
his expertise is in a very specific
location
how is he supposed to determine what's
what works for billions of people
that quote put it put it perfectly i
agree with that i completely do and
and again they're just people they're
just people
and if we're going to sort of pop
through this in any way shape or form
using technology which you know the
davos crowd loves that idea the only
thing i can imagine is that we actually
put ai in charge of something because ai
can manage
actual complex things but we might build
this program and we're going to hate
what it says
because it's going to do something it's
going to say
you shouldn't grow cotton in arizona
deserts
no strawberries in new york in the
winter sorry
right no avocado toast in new york in
the world
williamsburg explodes overnight huge
mess
we're gonna hate it well don't scrap
that that's obviously dumb
you know that's that's the funny thing
that i've been saying about
a lot of these big cities i see the
cities as being the problem
and it's not rural conservatives that
are the problem uh i i mentioned the
other day
people who live in rural areas well
water which is a sustaining
self-sustaining cycle for the most part
some areas get stripped and there's
problems but
typically if you live in the middle of
nowhere you got a well you don't got to
worry about it uh
you have septic systems which are also
in in to a great degree self-regulating
and if done properly
uh i i could be wrong about this but
we've had you know because we're on a
septic system
the guy who said if you do it right we
never have to come back out
however most people don't because that's
like a paper towel on the toilet is
doing it wrong
kind of thing yeah usually and and
plastics and cigarette butts and things
like that but you look at these cities
and uh they they they they must have
their strawberries in winter
and no matter how many times the climate
change activists say things like
hey we should stop eating out of season
fruits they themselves do it
you know what my absolute favorite
moment was it came yesterday you're
familiar are you familiar with the
sunrise movement
these are like the climate change
activists they're like we got to save
the planet
so last night in new york there was a
widespread alert
everyone's got to shut off their ac and
turn the power off because the
consumption was overloading the grid and
power was dropping out in certain areas
they said
stop unnecessary use of air conditioning
that's a fair point to be honest
some people don't realize this they'll
like they'll have maybe you're you're in
a two-bedroom apartment and you've got
ac
on in a room you're not in well why
don't you turn it off stay in one room
yeah help really alleviate some of the
stress the sunrise movement tweeted
what is unnecessary use of air
conditioning we're trying to survive
this deadly heat wave
and i'm like yo you're the closest 90.
but like these are the climate change
people arguing for the right to use air
conditioning
in these cities they they they
concentrate
all of the problems that they're
complaining about especially like police
brutality
but you think about a septic system
which is in many ways self-regulating
what do the cities do
gigantic sewer systems that dump the
sewage into the ocean or the lakes
this is the this is what blows my mind
chicago
all this all of the cities surrounding
the lake michigan
are dumping sewage into the lake and it
flows all right down to chicago where
everyone's got
dancing around it and on the beaches you
go to the middle of nowhere
that's not happening so cities are
are these giant dissipative structures
they just think
it's just food and energy go pouring in
and waste comes pouring out
which is cool as long as you have you
know a lot of food and energy and stuff
like that but
we're coming up in this period of time
it's going to get really awkward right
where we don't have quite the energy we
want to do all the things we want and
then we have to have those conversations
about what we're going to do
the right time was when jimmy carter put
his cardigan on and had a speech and
said maybe we should insulate our houses
better we were like nah
let's not that's okay so now we have
these excessive heating
cooling costs you know right so so if we
were going to do this in egalitarian way
i think we could come up with a with a
a currency cryptocurrency right tie it
to a barrel of oil so when it comes out
of the ground this currency is created
and then it gets consumed when the oil
gets used
so if bill gates wants to have a fleet
of jets and 60 houses
he's going to have to figure out where
to harvest those he's going to have to
buy them from me
and my price is going to be he'll have
to go out to the open market and get his
fair share of those things right this is
very hard to do
this is exactly what i i what i think is
happening is
people like bill gates he doesn't want
everybody out of poverty
i don't think he really cares maybe it's
some like fanciful nebulous goal like
wouldn't it be great if people weren't
in poverty i think he's actually
thinking like
wait you mean because of all of these
problems around the world i've got to
give up my jet
what if wait wait what if we get all of
the people of the united states to stop
flying
can i fly then well technically okay
good
that's what they keep doing they tell
everybody else to sacrifice
they keep their private jets i i'm
completely convinced that we cannot
legislate or use politics to get out of
this because telling people to change
does not make them change you need to
incentivize it with a better system
that functions better like the change
just where it's easier and more fun and
more useful
i think the problem is you've got evil
people who lie cheat and steal to gain
power
that's definitely part of the plan and i
think if we were if we were allowed to
have open and fair and honest
conversations
we wouldn't be in this problem in the
first place so look like bill gates was
on tv like constantly right
they're asking about the vaccine fact
what do you think bill what do you think
what do you think guys got a bunch of
money by the way i know people who've
worked for him directly
he's a full-on sociopath psychopath he
was very he's not a great technologist
but he was very good at crushing his
competition
right so that's his genius great so he
made a pile of money but why does that
qualify him to suddenly be the world's
expert on vaccines
this was the the best thing about the
rogan scandal
he called a scandal i guess when he gave
his opinion on vaccines
you you simultaneously had these
articles where they're like how dare joe
rogan give give advice he's not a doctor
bill gates says here's his advice on
medical treatments
and then i tweeted about that and
someone responded because bill gates is
saying what's in line
with these organizations and i'm like
then why not write the article saying
cdc recommends instead of bill gates
you see the point and and pay no
attention to the fact that the bill and
melinda gates foundation funds a lot of
the same organizations that are saying
the things that he's in alignment with
right their tentacles go far they
they're i think they're like half the
who's budget
they fund gavi they find all these
things i saw a really funny meme that
said i'm not going to take advice from a
guy who thinks population growth is a
problem
like he's talking about how do we
control the population manage it
properly
you see this is the funny thing this is
how they this is how the media
boxes people into the conspiracy theory
bubble bill gates gave a ted talk
where he was talking about eliminating
poverty and he explained several ways
that
several things we need to do in order to
achieve that i like the idea of
eliminating poverty but poverty is
relative
the only real way to eliminate poverty
is communism when you make everyone poor
eliminate wealth exactly exactly if
everyone's equally poor
but as long as there's someone who has
more there will be
a poverty bracket now in in his speech
he said
that the joke i made earlier where i did
the silly voice that uh you know we have
we have 6.4 billion people
we're looking at 9 billion in the next
several years if we have
with vaccinations health care and
reproductive health services
we can reduce that by about 10 to 15
percent he was talking about
out of control population growth reuters
fact
checked this and said all these people
are conspiracy theorists who believe
he's talking about culling humans he's
not
he's just saying we shouldn't have mass
population growth
okay that's the official narrative then
great if the guy
is is publicly speaking about
controlling the level of population
and it is publicly accepted and
fact-checked that that's the case
then i don't think he cares about you as
an individual and that's why i say
talk to your own doctor because because
the people who get advice from people
like bill gates or a comedian for that
matter
are not getting proper advice
but the problem joe rogan gets attacked
and what was joe's immediate response
i'm a [ __ ] listen to dr fauci
and i'm like no no no no no no fauci
doesn't know
anything about you like i said this
other day like we got like you got like
a lump on your butt the doctor says oh i
can't give you a treatment because the
lump on your butt
factory doesn't know about the lump on
your butt but you walk in front of a bar
get drunk and then they give you a
medical treatment
i say this too much but you know i i
it's frustrating it does bear repeating
but yeah that's where we're at well
in particular um what i don't like is
is how science has become religious it's
become a religion for people and
scientism
scientism it's a great term for it so
pope fauci you know people like oh but
fauci said as if
it was an infallible thing i've caught
that guy in more misstatements lies and
scientific errors
you know that's it's a little hobby of
mine and i've been i've been doing it
for over a year
he's he's he's a wreck he's a tv doctor
yeah
i understand what was the last time he
saw a patient do you think has it been
30 years
is that what they said at least he and
the guy hasn't like picked up a
scientific instrument he's been a
bureaucrat for 30 years that's fine
you know somebody can be smart and sit
down and learn stuff i i get that but
people talk about him as if he really is
the smartest guy out there you know how
hard it is to be a bureaucrat at his
level
do you know what his day is like it's
all emails and meetings and
politics we saw his emails leak we know
all about that stuff
so i love that he comes out you know if
they're criticizing me they're
criticizing science
that was that was a bridge too far that
was that's a bridge too far
that was just you said it twice too
double down yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i view him as a tv doctor of
course he's not dr phil
but he's literally a guy who doesn't
who's not seeing patients who's not
currently in academia he works for the
government reviewing
what what does he do he reviews grants
and things like that and then he goes on
tv and gives his opinions
but he's not the guy in the lab so when
this all started happening last year
we saw his emails like what did we see
he started asking people in labs hey
what's going on with this was this one
of ours can you give us advice
he didn't know so i i noticed this
very early on i was like i like fauci
he's all right you know he's he's doing
his best
he's trying to tell us what he can and
then after a few instances where
he would come out and give advice i was
like you know hold on a minute what he
just said
that was on cnn two days ago he's just
repeating what they said two days ago
then when he contradicted himself that
was that's
where i started to be like wait a minute
the dude just waited two days after the
news said something and then repeated it
yeah he's just he's just i love how they
complained that trump
would be sitting in his you know chair
watching fox news and then he would
tweet what he saw on fox news
i'm like what do you think is doing he's
watching cnn and then they ask him to
come on and create this recursive loop
where cnn says here's what we're
learning and then fauci goes yeah here's
what we're learning
and the double masking thing was the
perfect example of the recursive loop of
non-science
he gets asked randomly now doesn't it
doesn't it make it makes sense that
people wear two masks
would be better off yes absolutely two
masks would be would be common sense
and then all of a sudden people start
saying fauci says we should all wear two
mess
so then he comes out and says you don't
need to be wearing two masks
and then all of a sudden the cdc
announces we're now recommending two
masks and then factory comes back out
and says
you should probably be wearing two masks
and then they actually had
they actually had this this image a
camera board channel was cnn where it's
like
three masks and then the meme came out
about like 12 17 20.
that was the perfect example of the
recursive loop of fauci watches tv
it repeats and then there's it's
repeated in the press and then it gets
adopted
politically it's just it's it's not
science if he does it it's not science
if anybody does it and
and he also said that that same
interview is like i am science right
i am science everything i did was it was
scientifically backed up right but no
his first
admonition for people not to wear masks
he admitted later was a political
calculation we're saying well we didn't
really have enough
for the healthcare workers and the
people so we thought we'd sort of try
and steer people away so we could
preserve them that's not a scientific
decision that's a political decision
let's break this down he lied
let me just let me just express he said
he came out later i think it was like
july of last year he's like well we
didn't have enough masks for
all of our medical professionals and
they needed masks so that was the advice
we gave
however and this is what he said we
didn't realize
that people could spread covet
asymptomatically
so once we realized that we reversed of
course that okay no you you need to be
wearing masks here's the problem
so well listen listen
you don't need to go out and buy n95
masks you don't need to go out and buy
actual medical grade face masks you
could have wrapped a shirt around your
face and i've done it
fauci could have come out immediately
and said some you know look
if you've got a scarf or some some cloth
face covering
you might as well wear it it'll it'll
help out so by march
of 2020 there was this little shop in
southern california called the sway so
shop
and these women start making these face
masks and they bought themselves a
particle
intrusion detection machine for like
three grand and started testing
different things out found
all these different things and found one
brand of blue shop towel that was
as good as an n95 sowed that into their
mass and had it solved
so what if fauci had come out and said
look we have a problem this is again
back to my original point
they don't trust people i would trust
people in that position i say look
we screwed up we should have had mass on
on on store we should have
we should have been ready for a pandemic
we didn't we forgot to do that our bad
we won't do that again but we're going
to need your ingenuity please here's a
million dollar challenge anybody can
figure out how to make a better mask in
a sew shop go
and you would have seen this amazing
stuff happen but what would have been
amazing
what did we learn later that it wasn't
even about n95
it was that the masks may stop a droplet
and that's all we needed in which case
people
anything is better nothing in that
scenario i went to i went to home depot
we're buying we're buying wood because
we're like building ramp stuff
and they're like you need a mask and i
was like oh and i i i
walk back to the car i pull a t-shirt
from the back seat and i wrap it on my
face and they're like
good to go they were like yeah a t-shirt
folded over twice that's thicker than a
95.
you're great you got to remember they
don't stop droplets they absorb the
droplets
and then you got to wash them out you
got to wash them out i wish the first
day he came out was like you got to wash
your mask every day
you got to wash your mask my favorite
moment
it's iconographic so so the then surgeon
general at the time
he says he goes out and he's going to
show how to how to do the how the
t-shirt thing right
so he comes out and the t-shirt he picks
says got naloxone
right which is the antidote for an
opiate overdose
so i'm just i'm just thinking like just
metaphorically that surgeon general is
going
showing us how to fold up a got naloxone
t-shirt to make it into an impromptu
mask why so somebody he had somebody
picked that on purpose so i'm always
looking for the symbolism but i just
like that was bizarre
whoa you sometimes wonder why sometimes
things happen with this stuff and i was
like why
you want to believe there's some secret
conspiracy going on because they can't
be that
dumb right this is this is why i'm i
tell you they're just regular people
that was a really dumb decision right
there
someone maybe it was a it was a surgeon
general so they had they
pulled a shirt out of a box and said
here you go and he was like great and he
didn't think twice
yeah but there's a reason that shirt was
in that box that's for sure
it was when people started selling um
like like
masks that with like branding on it and
like pictures and stuff is when i knew
the shark had been in my opinion the
shark had been jumped oh dude i got ads
on facebook for like
it's like it's like this male model and
he's like looking all serious with these
special glasses he's got this sweater on
where the zipper is off to the side
and he's wearing a mask that's got like
sharp edges and points and it's
like fancy designer masks now you go to
we went to the mall and we bought a
bunch of silly games and puzzles
and there was a massive bin and it was
like it was like 75 percent off masks
buy two get one
buy one get one free and just like no
one's touching them
well now we got the delta variant though
now now they're saying that uh because
the delta variant
well so the cdc i believe the cdc
director said
if you vaccinated th then the the
variant is no issue
but la reinstituted their guidelines and
we're seeing lockdowns
in australia just in general because of
the covet strain and i think canada
as well has been lacking have you heard
about that canada maybe yep
in israel too considering it i'm
interested what exactly
is the delta variant are you familiar i
i am
how how long could you want to get it i
don't know it's kind of a cool story
yeah the one that youtube says that
we're allowed to talk about because we
are surfs to the youtube machine
sure so um we'll talk about the real the
more serious in-depth stuff
at timcast.com well this this makes the
delta variant sound a little bit
a little bit ominous so youtube's going
to love this
as long as it scares people i guess yeah
all right so so when we say a uh variant
what we're really talking about is
there's this genetic structure there's a
string of letters and some of those
letters change over time randomly
and every so often one of those random
changes makes it do something like be
more transmissive
and those if it makes it more
transmissive that survives better so
that's a variant because like
if it if it has a 80 better chance of
jumping from me to you that's the one
you get and then you get it and then
it's just boom right if if it were to
change and make it less transmissible
would it still be considered a variant
it would but it'd die out pretty quickly
in the overall thing because this is
survival of the fit it's just evolution
right so the the the virus
they can do the better transmissive job
is going to go farther
right so we had the first one was called
the d614 g and what that means the d
is an amino acid it got changed into a g
at the 6 14 position
that was the original one that's that
the so-called uk variant 40
more transmissive the delta has that has
all the old favorites
plus it has this last one which is uh
the p681r
now this turned a proline into an
arginine and this is really cool because
this virus has a really
funky thing that no related virus has
which is
what's called a poly basic fear and
cleavage site is this thing
this little four amino acid chunk that
sits between the two spike proteins when
it gets clipped
makes it go into your cell like that by
the way it's an old trick if you're
doing gain a function in the lab that's
an exact insert that you would put at
that exact location by the way we've
done that 11 times
for other things and made them more more
better at being bad
right so it has this really weird thing
well that with that p
is the one that got changed so this
thing now we think the data says gets
into your cells
even faster and better so that's the
ominous part
the good news is i don't have data to
say it's any more harmful oh okay
yep well people still take it seriously
and talk to their doctors
about what's right for them they should
because he's like doc i'm worried about
the p681r there
and your doctor will go why i'm so glad
you explained p 681r means
the p turned into an r yep at the 681
position
yep thank you cool that's how that works
so so
but it's way more transmissive way more
yeah so
so uh this i guess the cdc is saying
though that you're fine if you're
vaccinated
that you don't have to worry about this
new variant that's what they're saying
but
but everybody's favorite other doctor
doctor scott gottlieb who they never
mentioned serves on the border fizer as
saying maybe a third shot would be a
good thing to do
in order to they've talked about
boosters yeah johnson and johnson
yeah let me make sure i can pull some of
this stuff up too yeah so that's where
they're going with that um
i think the vaccines at best we can say
they're partially protective at this
point in time the uk
will be rolling out covet 19 booster
shots in september yep so they're
they're going to be having
and there was a story in nbc that really
freaked me out and uh i know
you guys you don't want to hear me say
it but i have to say it again
there's a story from nbc that said mix
and match and it said some experts were
advocating for
taking multiple different kinds and i'm
just like stop stop
no no nbc which experts i hate when they
say experts
what are they talking about it was like
uh it was an nbc article
i i gotta pull this one up i gotta pull
this i gotta find this one but that's
why i'm just like
i'm pretty sure if you go to your doctor
and you ask them they'll be like no no
no no no don't do that let me uh let me
see if i can find the story because we
have the one about uk is going to be
introducing boosters i want to know what
benefit there would come from mixing and
matching them do you see any kind of
benefit chris
not i can think of off top my head so so
so uh not really
just just to bring it up this is nbc
news mix and match covet vaccine
approach
boosts immune response study fines now i
will state as far as i can tell the fda
is not approved of that practice
okay there you go but consult your
doctor
yeah some european countries have
started offering alternatives to
astrazeneca and a second shot after the
vaccine was linked to rare blood clots
so
they this is nbc news and it's cover
it's
it's a story by reuters here's the best
part there's no byline
there's no violence this is a major
taboo in journalism we're launching the
newsroom for tim castle
and and i'm very much always like we
must
have bylines and bios for all of our
reporters people need to know who wrote
it
and then be able to email that person
with corrections and our corrections
department
and we're gonna have fact checkers when
it just says buy reuters
like source reuters okay i suppose i can
maybe take let me let me see if i can
dig deeper we'll do this in real time
let's see if i can take mix and match
kovid search that
and reuters and uh
there we go all right and now okay so we
do have a name we
we find the name now alistair smout mix
and match approach boost immune response
of astrazeneca shot study finds when nbc
news doesn't put a byline on it
they have automatic news articles that
publish so what they'll do is
they'll have specific parameters like
temperature
forecast for weather and then an article
will automatically be generated saying
the the the the five-day forecast for
you know tallahassee florida is today
will be sunday by tomorrow you can
expect to see clouds
completely automatically generated they
do the same thing with sporting events
mma and football or whatever it'll be
like you know the the raiders scored a
goal in this quarter in that quarter and
did this and they'll show you all the
stats
written by a robot you got to watch out
for those things
well well you do and it was uh the
snowden leaks back in 2013 which so
show that the gchq had
bots that were so good at writing
comments under
under all the major newspapers that
people couldn't detect what was what
so that's been a thing for a long time
trust me things have gotten a lot better
since 2000
stuff in the live chat sometimes where
it will be two comments back to back
that will say different things
in all caps about for instance me it'll
be like ian's the best ian's the worst
but it'll be at the exit they'll come at
the exact same time two different
accounts
all caps and it's like very weird that
those could be two people
one one of the reasons i i tweeted
before
stop responding to people who don't use
real names and and photos and see your
political discourse improve
one of the reasons i tweeted that it was
it was a sub tweet i was tweeting about
you know certain trolls but one of the
one of the main issues is that we've
long known that governments use what's
called sock puppets
they use one person will have 50
accounts
and they'll bombard you with an opinion
to make you think
it is public opinion people fall for
this
like crazy sure you'll get a small pizza
restaurant we'll announce they're having
a uh you know like
the the proud boys are gonna have a
meeting at some restaurant the
restaurant owner has no idea
and then one day the restaurant owner
gets 40 you know emails or whatever and
they're all from different people and
different names saying why are you
hosting white supremacists and nazis
and they'll be like whoa oh what are all
these things there's probably one person
doing it
that's why it's like i want to know who
i'm talking to
and uh within reason i still will engage
in conversations with people who don't
use
you know names or or photos or anything
like that sometimes people want to be
anonymous for an obvious reason we
talked about this
but i'm just pointing that out that if
we're in the space where we're like
we are not going to stand by our names
and have these conversations
then you have a massive exploit
in your face from activist groups and
i'll tell you one thing
conservatives are not engaging in this
i'm sure some are
but they are not as politically savvy
and organized as
the mainstream left is and the
intelligence agencies
so when it comes to engaging with sock
puppets it is probably two to one that
you're engaging with a leftist sock
puppet who's lying to you then you would
be someone on the right
but it exists on both sides well we know
information is power and so of course
this power has not been left to its own
devices and this isn't this goes way
beyond citizens i remember
there was this really embarrassing
moment i think read it when it you know
was first
coming out and it's really starting to
explode i can't remember the year i'd
have to look it up 2013 to 15 somewhere
in there and they said
hey where's our traffic coming from i
think it was on like our data is
beautiful so they looked and they looked
at the ip accounts and oh my gosh
wouldn't you know there's this one
little town in north carolina that like
blew everybody else out of the water
and that's where fort hood's located and
they have an operational
center for information control right and
then and then i think they vpn'd it and
got rid of that little like data signal
but it was just it was pretty obvious to
me what was happening then
right so information is actually power
so when you see comments you have to
know
first question ought to be is this real
because it might be it might not be we
don't know
we just don't know but information is
power yeah yeah which is why
um when the new york you saw the new
york mayoral election thing happen
eric adams is like yo what's with all
these extra votes yeah hey
all these liberal journalists come out
saying you're trumpian
you're lying this is ridiculous you're a
sore loser even though he's winning
yeah and then it turns out that the
auction board was like oh actually yeah
he was right
sorry about that but you see the
immediate reaction from the
establishment is protect
the machine at all costs right don't
challenge don't question don't
investigate
when i when i went to do the sweden
investigation
donald trump goes on he's at a rally and
he goes did you see what happened last
night in sweden
it's terrible and then uh there they the
media explodes like what happened last
night in sweden trump what are you
talking
he was talking about a documentary he
watched on fox news last night
and so he didn't speak as clearly enough
i announced i did a gofundme i'm like
hey i'm going to raise money to go to
sweden and actually investigate because
i'd worked for vice i'd worked for
disney and i had done these kinds of on
the ground
documentary investigations and i had
journalists i knew from vice message me
saying do not go
and i was confused i was like what do
you mean i was like one guy one of the
guys i went to ukraine with
and i'm like you we went to ukraine
together to investigate stuff like why
wouldn't i go to sweden and he goes
just don't do it give the money away
give it to charity and i was like uh
i raised money to go to report
journalism it would be fraudulent if i
gave it away i have to refund it
and then i got another message from
someone saying don't fuel their
conspiracies and i was like
do you think the conspiracies are true
because if i
actually go i'm assuming i'm going to
prove them wrong and they're like no
don't go creepy people i knew and worked
with all of a sudden were just like
do not challenge the machine and that
was just about the machine
it was weird what do you think that was
really about i have no idea
it's it's a cult man and i maybe i say
cult a lot and people are like
you know tim saying cult again uh when
when
people i worked with advice who are low
level reporters and they get paid trash
we fly around reporting stories one day
just instinctively
defend the machine how did no one told
them
to message me there's no handler like
they're not secretly part of some
government agency
they were just so indoctrinated they
were like don't you dare report on any
of this
because we said no and i'm like i i'm
i'm genuinely confused by what you're
talking about and i went
and then slate these lefties loved that
i came back saying like yeah there's not
really
that much crime it's like so it's it
there are problems here
crime is going up but relative to most
places and and the problems of sweden
were very very nuanced it wasn't like a
bunch of immigrants came in
a year ago and then caused problems
there's actually the children of
immigrants for 20 years ago there's a
lot a lot of nuance there
and sweden really screwed things up but
i was just
to experience that whole thing was a
very strange experience
from having people i knew and worked
with saying do not report
don't do journalism and i'm like but i
always do journalism it was like
it's like brain slugs infected their
bodies and took them over it was the
weirdest thing
and then going to sweden experiencing
the message control
when when all of the media aligned
against me
after we got into this conflict in an
area called rinkeby
it was weird to see how coordinated the
machine was
creepy has it always been like that or
do you think it's getting worse
i think it's getting worse and what
could explain that so
so back to this idea of leaders and
followers i have this this theory that
that that things are getting so
tense for people right so so
young people in particular i i've just
had this this event this really nice
young kid
comes up he's in is in teens he's in
college he's like thanks for what you do
um i have a question like what would you
do if you're me
he's like i'm studying but i don't
believe in the future at all and he's
coming up with
this existential dread which is i'm
supposed to live into this story here's
my story
go to school get good grades uh come out
get a job
you're supposed to plan on all this
stuff meanwhile what's your school
telling you oh hey the ice caps are
melting and this whole thing's about to
go up in flames
you know it's hard to sort of square
that circle and so i think confronted
with that people
start to um cling to anything
including maybe you know obedience to
the machine or something i think it's
just
i think it's a big defense for sure it's
part of why information is so powerful
like what you said earlier because if
you can give them
a path or a reason to live or a solution
or at least an idea of a solution like
yeah
iron fertilization we can repopulate the
salmon have you studied iron
fertilization you yeah they're going to
get the
you know carbon out of them you can read
algae blooms or whatever the coral reefs
uh it also feeds the salmon the iron
creates plankton which then the salmon
can eat and so we can regrow the fish
population of earth we can regrow the
coral by shattering it and placing it
all over and then it all grows together
and forms giant wreaths
like there are solutions if people don't
know they get scared and then they
look to they want a leader and they look
to people like anthony fauci who's like
the tv leaders that pop up
reality tv stars actors you know i i
feel like
people don't want to have any
responsibility they just want to be told
what to do
i don't know i if i know what to do i
like it i like it the line said it bro
you don't even get to do anything the
cdc just says do it you just do it
like okay well you know look within
reason i do respect cdc guidance
i say within reason because you know i
know tuskegee for instance
but uh uh you have personal
responsibility
yes they can give you advice but
ultimately it's on you to go and seek
out what's right for you which includes
talking to your doctor or perhaps
becoming a doctor
well yeah that's true the bright spot
that came for me out of all this
covid stuff was um really looking into
things like certain supplements and
whatnot and real
and realized that i had bought into a
bunch of junk
that my culture had given me including
my doctor literally telling me
vitamins are just an expensive way to
take a leak right
you know you eat them and you piss them
out right but water soluble
vitamin d i have this whole crazy story
on how important vitamin d
is and and it's an amazing story and
fauci said so
well only because jennifer garner asked
him on her v-log
she was star struck so he did admit to
taking vitamin d but he never came out
and said you should
i thought he did i thought he said
vitamin d is good and people should be
it's still on the nih treatment
guidelines right now
under covet it says there's neither
enough data to to refute or endorse
no wow vitamin d but there's tons of
data
you know what i found um i i like
winters are
you know like i feel i don't like
winters i like the cold
and then uh this past year i started
wondering like why why am i like so
energized and energetic and jumpy and
like full of
you know just ready to go why do i
escape better in the summers and in the
winter
even indoor it's harder and i'm like
dude it's vitamin d
vitamin d i'm not getting enough
sunlight i'm inside it's air it's it's
heated
and there's less sunlight so i i i got
some vitamin d gummies and i felt
fantastic yeah
i was like i'm not getting enough the
more you study vitamin d it's like it's
not a vitamin it's a hormone it's like
involved in all these things and it's
about inflammation and and bone repair
it's like crazy good stuff
and almost everybody is deficient in it
particularly
dark-skinned people because you're the
melon in your skin
particularly at higher latitudes
prevents the sun from coming in the uvb
rays and making the vitamin d so
like if you or i took our shirt off and
you know we'd get like 10 000 units in
like 15 minutes right but
but of course consult your doctor before
taking any vitamin or
taking your shirt off
is there a difference in the value
biochemically of of getting
producing vitamin d naturally from
sunlight or
taking a vitamin d supplement they're
probably well so the vitamin d from
sunlight has its own
regulation process where you can't oh
you can't get too much it'll shut itself
down
if you you could technically take too
much but it's a big big big number
right it's a really big number it's a
fat soluble no it's a hormone
is it yeah it's found soluble yeah yeah
the water-soluble stuff you just kind of
piss out but the fat soluble stuff you
can get really sick on
right like vitamin a it takes well
that's a different story but um vitamin
d takes a lot like you would have to
take
mass at my weight for myself it would be
a huge number i i i was reading about
um like general health and dieting a
long time ago and i read that we don't
get enough vitamin c in our diets
it was something like for every 50
pounds an animal weighs they produce
something like a thousand
milligrams of vitamin c or something
like that i don't know if that number is
maybe you know
it it's true so so we're one of only
three mammals that can't make vitamin c
we had some
weird mutation that that bollocks this
up for us a long time ago
every other animal does it particularly
when they get stressed so a goat that's
like breaks its leg or something that
they've done
the studies will manufacture 60 grams of
vitamin c in the next 24 hours oh that's
a lot
that's a huge amount yeah and by the way
you can't take that much because you
can't tolerate it
through your gi tract so that's why they
do high-dose vitamin c now
when somebody's coming in with like
full-blown sepsis multi-organ shutdown
they pump the vitamin c and they're
insane amazing how it recovers them what
what does vitamin c do like is there a
process by which it's converted into
hydrogen peroxide or something like that
no it it's the precursor for pretty much
every stress hormone you're gonna make
this is gonna help you get through that
stressful process right cortisol
cortisone things like that
it's also really important for collagen
repair and things like that so linus
pauling two-time
nobel prize winner he's getting on in
his years and and so you know
sometimes old guys lose the story or
plot line that's what they tried to say
about this guy but in lateness careers
like vitamin c is the bomb he had all
this data four hundred thousand records
from gi's
and noted that when this was all before
computers they had to hand track this
he noted over time that the people who
had the higher vitamin c levels at
check-in when they got their physicals
had much lower levels of heart disease
so right around that same time though
the drug companies like oh you see
people have the plaques in their
arteries and we look in the plaques we
see cholesterol so let's take
cholesterol down he was like
you got it all wrong bucky that's not
what's happening that cholesterol is
there to try and repair the damage the
damage is
happening before and it's because we
don't have vitamin c so he comes up and
he puts vitamin c in and all of a sudden
they're showing that they're clearing up
people's um atherosclerosis within
months
if they have adequate cholesterol that's
doing it with the help of the vitamins
and the cholesterol is there to help
repair the damage that's already
happening
but you could be wrong i could be wrong
and you should talk to your doctor
that's right
no but uh it's guinea pigs they don't
make vitamin c right i'm not sure about
that one there's some bat and i forget
what the other one is
guinea pigs i think don't pigeons not
make vitamin c either
not sure about pigeons i was reading
something a long time ago i read his
book
about that is there any explanation it
was saying that
the um and again i'm i'm not an expert
in this as like
10 years ago i read this thing it said
that the amount we're told is our daily
100
is the minimum to avoid scurvy okay and
that
if you look at like you said 60 grams
yeah so what what what do we what do we
take like 60 milligrams
you might take 60 500 or 1000 milligrams
or something like that but again it
depends how much can actually be
absorbed at that time
so our gut really limits that so if you
get in in real serious
situation good doctors now will give you
that right iv because you can put a lot
in
through iv you can really cram it good
doctors with good opinions
well well i'll tell you so i work with
these you know doctors who are figuring
all this stuff out and they've got this
great story around vitamin c which
sounds a lot like
all these other stories we've been
talking about right where there's a
whole medical establishment that really
hates the idea and they try and
pooh-pooh it and they design studies to
fail and these guys are just like look
you know when somebody comes into an icu
with multi-organ failure for sepsis
right
they can take the average death rate
from around fifty percent and knock it
down to about eight percent and they can
do it reliably and repeatedly and if i
end up in the icu i want these
guys treating me period and they're and
they're they're doing intravenous like
vitamin c
that's the first thing they do that like
even before they take your first vital
sign
they get that drip going right so then
some other doctors say well let's study
that so they design it so that
they administer it within 24 hours of
showing up and these guys are like no
every minute counts they can prove that
every minute
counts and so these guys set up these
these studies and start it within a day
and of course it has a much lower um
efficacy after that
so what do we what do we say about a
system where people are incentivized
to design a trial to fail what if that
was you or your dad or your mom or
somebody you loved
in that that got enrolled in that i mean
how does how do we roll with that
information
it bothers me i've i've never uh
i don't i don't think i don't think
they're gonna let you die man
you know what i mean i think i think
that maybe sometimes people make bad
calls
sometimes a doctor will use his best
judgment but i don't think there's
anybody like twirling their mustache
maybe maybe at big pharma for sure but
like doctors and hospitals
belief systems are powerful enough that
people do crazy things when their belief
system is challenged
yeah that's that's for sure we talked
about the other day that um
another book i read a long time ago that
around 24 or so is when people's brains
start becoming like fully matured yeah
sort of solidifying their world
view mine was around 40. but that's keep
going but but they say that midlife
crisis happens when the brain
reopens to become oh that's what
happened to me so the so the
the idea is that if you've survived that
long
your brain is telling you the things
you've learned have kept you alive
hold on to them because if we maintain
this we can survive longer
so what happens then is if you present
evidence that is in
undeniable to somebody whose worldview
is solidified maybe somebody who's 30
their their brain will start panicking
because they're like no no
no we can't accept this it puts us at
risk and so their brain switches to
anger mode
and then they shut down the logical
process centers and go right into how
dare you
yeah and they start ad hominem and they
just go nuts and i'm sure people have
experienced this
have an argument with somebody and then
they just snap and you're like why are
you so
mad whoa well that's how you know you've
touched into a belief system so if you
have an opinion right you say
oh i think uh this is the best baseball
pitcher here's my stats and i come up
with different stats and we you know
trade stats for a while it's all cool
but if you have an opinion about
something
that's fine if you have a belief system
it's the emotions
yeah that was uh that was in dogma chris
rock says that he said something like
that
he's like an idea can change but beliefs
those are harder to change and people
die for beliefs
yeah i have a lot of ideas they you know
the joke is uh someone once
someone once commented on a youtube
video saying tim pool's a milk toast fen
sitter and i'm like hey let's roll with
that one and i used it
it's technically not true because i get
really angry about freedom free speech
civil rights and things like that but
for a lot of things like i got some
ideas
but i don't think like if i'm not an
expert on uh uh
you know cancer i'm not gonna tell
people what to do with cancer i have no
idea
you know it was making me think about
like um the scientific community and how
like theories and and
hypotheses are battled amongst like like
in um
quantized inertia for instance is a new
theory by uh mike mccauley he's been
working on it and there's a lot of
pushback because it does away with dark
matter in his theory so the people that
have theorized dark matter
don't want their theories to be lost and
upended because then their creds are
diminished and
so uh actually there's somebody i know
very very well
but well i'll let them retain their
privacy whose father was a physicist
and i i was asking about string theory
and
m theory and he explained that there's a
big problem right now
with at the time this was 10 years ago
so i don't know about physics he was
explaining
there's actually a lot of problems they
can't figure out when it comes to string
theory and m theory that
have many people believing it's probably
not correct the problem is
nobody wants to give up their life's
work they spent 40 years
working on these theories and the math
and you want to come and tell them now
it's all wrong
they can't accept that that's very hard
to do i believe it was the physicist
niels bohr who said
science advances one funeral at a time
that's why it's so brutal because but
it's true yeah it's true and and so when
it comes to like this whole area
of this medical stuff we've been talking
about it's really important to
understand that
if somebody's belief system is in the
way of you and your health
you need to detect that well and then
find somebody whose belief system maybe
is
is more flexible that's why there's a
lot of people who are like
who have messaged me saying you know my
doctor didn't know and i'm like bro
there's other doctors out there
yeah the sec a second opinion is like a
normal thing
so didn't know was okay doesn't want to
know is not okay
right i've i've had a lot of people
message me say my doctor i gave them the
data i'm giving them papers
and they're like don't give me that
stuff i'm not interested
right i say find a different doctor
absolutely that's what you do then right
we had um we were talking we were
talking with somebody i can't remember
but they mentioned
that they had a doctor who told them
some gave him some political response to
their question and so they said
and they called the different doctor and
said i don't care for the politics just
tell me like here's my age she's my
family
and then the doctor's like here's what
we're going to do here's what makes
sense based on the criteria not the
politics
there's a whole article that just came
out about um doctors who've banned it
together who are so scared of the
woke-ness
that these are typically older doctors
you know they've been in practice a
decade or more
um men and women doctors and and what
they're afraid of is that they see these
younger doctors coming in who won't
treat because somebody has the wrong
ideology right
like you know if uh that i think that
person's a skinhead or a republican or a
proud boy yeah i won't treat them or
they won't give them the same quality of
treatment but they're open about it and
so this is really terrifying
right to get to that level because now
we're into the us versus them now you've
started to dehumanize
and that's that's when you know you're
getting pretty far down the path so
let's let's
yeah so so just a quick quick aside on
this
i was speaking at this conference this
really sharp guy comes up afterwards
takes me to the side
asks you know he's said this guy had
worked for several joint chiefs of staff
and um was pretty connected in and said
by the way when you were talking chris
about um
that we were going to attack north korea
this was like i don't know five years
ago i was reading all these signs
and i knew we were about to do that
because i suddenly saw all these
articles come out new york times about
how
prison guards in north korea were like
kicking puppies and like
just you know doing stuff we were
dehumanizing so i watched the
dehumanization happen
and so i wrote out to my my followers
i'm like hey looks like things are about
to heat up with north korea this guy
came up in just a couple years after the
fact and said
you have no idea how right you were we
were we had two carrier groups in that
moment and they were all spooled up and
we were ready to go
how did they need how did you know and i
said it was easy new york times was
printing stuff about how
how inhumane the guards were in the
prisons over there you never see and it
came out in four
newspapers at once they need to rally
public support right
let's talk about this dehumanize first
that's what you do we'll talk about this
fauci
um was doing an interview he said that
it's almost like there are two americas
due to people who are not getting the
vaccine
and uh it's it's fascinating he's
correct i've talked about this before
let's say you live in texas where they
have no restrictions no lockdowns
i think it's oregon that started saying
they want to implement vaccine passports
so if you're from texas no more tourism
in oregon
not that a lot of texans wanted to go
there anyway like to be completely
honest probably other way around people
fleeing portland to texas
but let's say you're in florida you want
to go to new york well new york says
we're going to do the excelsior pass for
like
madison square garden you got to be able
to prove your vaccination status so you
can't so
can't go see the foo fighters so now
people in states without the
restrictions who are abiding by the law
and regulations and guidelines
won't be able to go to other states
now that is where it gets crazy because
for the longest time we have we have
open travel between states
when this whole thing started we had
there were there were checkpoints set up
at new york
going in and they would you know i don't
know exactly what they were doing but
there were stories that
from like new york to content to
connecticut connecticut had
um police at the border checking plates
that were from new york because they
were like new york's a hot spot
so we're actually starting to see a
re-emergence of borders in the u.s
and laws that prohibit people from free
travel or from
actually being able to use
accommodations public accommodations in
certain states
does that apply to amazon drivers too
and truck drivers
yes and this is where a lot of people in
our super chats have brought this up
that a truck a trucker who's from say
nebraska
is going to be dr they're like hey this
one's going to new york can't go sorry
oh well this one's going to oregon oh
yeah i can't go there
well he could but he's gonna have to
drive around this one state right well
let's say the destination is is oregon
and they're like well no they're doing
vaccine passports in oregon
the guy's gonna say where do i go to the
bathroom and get food i'm not going
sorry find someone else to drive and
we're already dealing with apparently
the shortage with truckers
so now a bunch of people that there's
fuel like gas stations aren't getting
the fuel they need
you add in these heavy restrictions
which so far hasn't taken off
for the most part but we we are seeing
it happen in certain areas
it's not even about hardband that's what
people need to understand
you don't need to ban people who aren't
vaccinated you need only apply
pressure so that could mean oh you can
everyone's free to come here vaccinated
or unvaccinated but if you're not
vaccinated you gotta go in the back
that's pressure and some people are
gonna say i'm not i'm not interested in
being the guy in the back room so have a
nice day
portland can say we don't truckers are
allowed to come don't worry
we're not banning people who aren't
vaccinated but you can't go
to these select gas stations and these
restaurants are off limits
and most of the companies here are
required it so you'll f you'll figure it
out they're like i'm not i'm not i'm not
taking that stress
so that that pressure is enough to
dramatically
alter this country i find it fascinating
when you have all this talk of peaceful
divorce
due to the extremism the violence and
now you have actual bureaucratic
pressure
which is starting to emerge two americas
yeah
you got that you got that divide and
conquer thing going on and
um i mean this is this should just be
completely common sense there are some
people
who cannot take these vaccines right
right so if you've already had an
anaphylactic reaction in a prior
vaccine episode which has happened a lot
of people you are not a candidate it
says right on the cdc website
right which apparently you can still get
in trouble for quoting this stuff right
but there it is
and they say oh by the way and if you've
had the first shot and you have a really
bad reaction that passes certain
threshold you shouldn't get the second
so you are now not fully vaccinated on
and on
it's a complex situation there there is
a a band
i forgot their name i don't care they
said a thousand dollars to see the the
the event but uh a discount if you're
vaccinated it'll only cost you 18
yeah i saw that and there was a woman
who was a fan who gave an interview
where she said
because she had kovid recently the
doctors told her she was ineligible for
the time being
and she had to come back later so that
meant she wasn't able to go to the show
but guess what rich people
come on in baby it's all yours it's a
rich man's world
yeah it has been for 10 000 years or
something
well and here's the problem with all
this it it doesn't logically you can't
parse your way through it doesn't make
sense
so so if we let's go back to first
principles what's the point of all this
the point of all this should be public
health i guess yes right
yes i don't know anymore to be honest i
don't know either sustention of human
life no i it's society and species yes
that
should should be but certainly uh never
let a good crisis go to waste
right that's the saying there's a lot
and it was interesting because uh we had
destiny
uh here he's the he's like a leftist
streamer and i said
you know it looks like we're seeing
people exploit the crisis
and he goes when else would you try and
make sweeping changes in reforms
you know this what what better time than
now when where we have to lock things
down now's our opportunity
and i'm like then would you trust every
move made if you knew
people were simply saying we got a
crisis great let's let's let's do a
bunch of things we always wanted to do
oh so that means um let's support uh
people going to mcdonald's and getting
crystal green dominance and shopping at
walmart but we're going to shut down
small and medium-sized enterprises right
you know this is
is that the crisis they wanted to
exploit we want we want the little
people to take it in the shorts i
thought that was not a lefty thing
i gotta admit though there is a
confusion there is a real problem with a
lack of personal responsibility people
should not be gorging on donuts and
mcdonald's and they should be
you know doing better eating better and
exercising and uh
but it's a personal responsibility 100
right it is
and it is that's the conversation i wish
that was on the news every day is how to
get healthy
yeah right how to feel better but they i
i think this is
this is uh exclusively of the democrats
well i shouldn't say exclusively but
it's the rule not the exception where
they want you dependent they want you
dependent they want you on social
programs
they want you to feel like no matter
what you do you'll never succeed without
their help
it's free look at this what's what's the
critical race theory message
you are oppressed and no matter what you
do because the color of your skin you
will always be oppressed
or oppressor and you need us to help you
to navigate these problems versus the
other message of you can be anything you
want to be if you believe in it
too many leaders they don't want too
many leaders what's the what's a good
ratio of leader to follower in the human
race
one yeah one to one no no
yeah one to nine billion one one
despotic king
no one to nine billion what is it like
one to one to twelve
one to sixty it's it's not five it's no
no but hold on it's not about one leader
at all it's about
specialists you know if uh
if if someone came in this room and said
i need to know what magic cards to buy
i'd be like take it away ian like yeah
lightning no i like that ball lightning
it holds a special place
no i mean like what are you what are you
an expert in if someone came in and said
i need someone to fix the toilet i'd beg
and any ian
like you're not a plumber so you're a
leader in the right moment
and so you know leaders step up when
they're
when they're called into action oh yeah
and you can inspire people to to
to seize their ability to lead yeah
everyone's good at something
dude if uh uh if if you know we had
someone out here and and they were a
farmer and a wildlife expert
and and and you know uh like a vacation
like a doctor you know like if someone
came out here and they were an expert in
plant life
i would immediately be like tell me
where to go what to do what to wear and
tell me how to find the fruits and that
guy's in charge
but then if he comes in and says we're
gonna do we're in talk podcasts i'll be
like okay well it ain't you buddy
like i'll i'll step up if we're doing a
podcast thing
you'll step up when you're doing a
fruits and berries in the forest thing
it's like recognizing where you are not
the leader and recognizing where you are
and then
so we have oligarchs or corporations
that are attempting to lead
the narrative when we have doctors that
are more specialized that maybe would be
better off deciding what
should and shouldn't be talked about
don't go to a dentist for foot care
right and don't go to a social network
for health care right oh i love it when
facebook is like
instagram is giving medical advice and
facebook is and all the celebrities are
and posting these things
but heaven forbid joe rogan have an
opinion or
a critical care doctor who's been eat
lives breathes drinks this and his
indisputable world leader on this stuff
right so but this says nothing about
that's why i said first principles it's
about public health it's clearly not
it's not about that it's about something
else so we can you know assign motives
and all that it's clearly about the
money it's about the benjamins it's
about power it's about seizing the
moment to
ram through some things that otherwise
couldn't have been rammed through it's a
pie chart
it's uh you know somewhere in there is
is a nice little chunk of public health
but then you you get greedy hands man
and people see an opportunity to exploit
a crisis
and you know what the path to hell is
paved with good intentions well listen
if if i saw them exploiting a way that i
could detect and say
okay i get it not how i do it but it
makes sense it does it's still
incoherent
it doesn't make sense to me right the
only thing that's starting to emerge in
this pattern is
as soon as i saw the climate lockdowns
we have to do climate lockdowns that's
when the pieces started to fall for me i
think
i think this well you take a look at
texas in florida
they were like ah we out so it's clearly
not
a unified message in terms of our
government there are different
jurisdictions with different beliefs and
different people are exploiting
different things
and i think one of the reasons it may
not be cohesive is just that
there's it's a chicken with his head cut
off man it's joe biden comes out
earlier this year this is this is one of
the most important points when he was
like we may have we may need more
lockdowns
while texas was like we're getting rid
of them and i'm like clearly joe biden
is not
speaking to the world view of red states
he was speaking to new york and
california
about what they want to do based on
their fears and their perceptions
so it's chicken with his head's cut head
cut off man back to chickens i like it
yeah chicken chickens
and you saw what joe rogan said um
recently he said we're just throwing
joe rook in this episode that it doesn't
feel like we have any real meaningful
leadership
like who who believes that we have a
real leader right now even the people
who voted for him
like do you really feel like he's
leading anything
i don't think so well no and and this is
this is the thing that
i think i'm i'm most concerned about so
if you if you go to a corporation or
you're in your own personal life you
develop a strategy at some point what's
a strategy
it's got two parts it's got a vision and
you need resources to get there
right guess what it's always easy to
have a vision hard to find the resources
so
you that you have to marry those things
up right so what's the vision of our
country where are we going to be in 30
years
right nobody can articulate that at this
point in time
right and without that we're just we're
rudderless we're just drifting along in
this story
i i i do hear you but i think it's
fairly obvious that what you said 30
years
so we're talking we're talking about
2051 it's going to be barron trump uh
he'll be on his second or third term
you know uh don junior will be doing
dynasties i'm just kidding
you know i'm sure there's a lot of
people who believe that the trump
dynasty
and you know whatever and uh what's the
country going to look like are we living
are we all in mansions are we in tiny
homes are we eating like algae
like what's going on you can grow algae
too
yeah um no i think i think it's going to
be
uh lab-grown foods i think we're going
to have kind of like protein mush
that is flavored so like like in the
matrix after you've taken the red pill
and you're in the ship
you've pulled that little gruel bowl out
but that's actually a black-pilled
version of it
you're going to go to the store and
you're going to say i'll have the chili
dog
with extra cheese and i'll get a large
cola with a large fry and it's all made
of the same thing but flavored
differently
so your your hot dog comes out and the
bun is actually like a protein
fungus the hot dog itself is a is a
thicker denser protein fungus
your drink is flavored by sugars
cultivated from a protein fungus
you see where i'm going with this the
french fries are just long mushrooms or
something like that
could be but i i think that we're going
to run into trouble with that idea
yeah yeah it it it's so much more
complicated
how nature actually works so there's
these micronutrients macronutrients it's
not just giving you like the base
calories which is sugar you know it's
some some little thing
we need all these things like trace
amounts of selenium
magnesium and maybe we'll we'll work all
that out right
but your your needs are going to be
different from your needs because your
gut biom's different you have a
different genetic structure
it's just different you're right it's
it's not you're familiar with silent
yeah the the company soylent tried
making this this food replacement
and it was interesting the idea was
can't we just
figure out exactly what a person needs
and give it to them and they don't have
to worry about eating
no no because we are not uniformly
produced in a factory
every single person is different and
every day that person is different than
they were the day before
and so the problem is if you were to say
drink this bottle like it first
came in like a powder form with like a
thing of oil and you have to because you
need fat in your diet
and then they were like okay the problem
is some people are taller and require
more we're not giving enough
some people are small and they're
getting too much and they're getting
sick so now it's just like a meal
replacement shake
that's in my opinion what like slim fast
they already they make those things it's
got 30
35 of your you know daily vitamins and
you drink it and it replaces one meal
but you still got to eat because you
don't know what you're missing
didn't that last for like a month and
then people like their their bowels were
just like ruined or whatever
it didn't really work out i don't think
well it's because they they quickly
realized
i'm pretty i could be wrong about this
but i'm pretty sure before they went
public like with the actual product
they said we realized you can't actually
sustain yourself on this also the
branding i mean soylent
that was the joke it's people soylent
green is people soylent's probably not
people
you know i'm really into vertical
farming okay oh i'm into vertical
farming
indoor vertical farming like aerofarms
in jersey is the largest one largest
vertical farms where i think that the
future
of humanity might be like a vertical
farm on every block or something in a
city
yeah but you know what they grow they
grow they grow lettuce greens in those
things yeah right and they don't grow
like corn and wheat and stuff they throw
them on mesh so without soil and they'll
spray the mesh with like a nutrient
but i'm wondering what's the difference
of food being grown indoors
as opposed to outdoors and natural
sunlight well there's a lot of
advantages for indoors but but for that
stuff again we're growing greens like
really high value you're getting some
arugula but man does not live on arugula
alone
you know so so it's just i think they're
cute
i think they have a role but to say
that's how we're going to feed people
now we got to talk megatons you know
like
how many how many millions of tons of
food product is coming out of those
and also notice where the energy comes
from those are all leds are very
efficient but where's the electricity
come from for that
right you just you follow this along and
you say look we already have this
nuclear reactor it's 93 million miles
away safely
it's a good distance and it provides
that service for free i'm now learning
that uh where where where i live and
what we have growing
we'd probably be able to cover a large
portion of our diets maybe like even 60
or 70 percent just with
there's ev every day potatoes deer oh my
gosh
no dear everywhere just like they're
they're they're the people
out here tell me that they're pests
they're they're a nuisance there's so
many but once you really started living
on them here's the thing i'm i'm a
hunter
so the deer are everywhere until the day
of hunting season i swear to god and
they're all gone
it's almost like they don't want to be
shot it's the strangest thing well no
but like i
today every morning i see like three
deer walking through the yard
and they're eating my apples and i'm
like stop eating jerks reaching up in
the trees and telling them
but we got three apple trees they're
just they're i
i don't know if they're wild actually
looks like they were actually planted
we've got tons of wild pawpaw
the mulberry trees are everywhere and
everyone's mad about mulberries are
awesome because they produce fruit for
90 days
like strawberries is like a week you
know yeah but 90 days
you just get mulberries we're gonna we
took a hammock like just
and we held it underneath and shook some
branches and we got like 300.
it was insane there's too many yeah you
walk in the yard and your feet are
turned purple and i'm like
we should actually start actually
foraging and harvesting these edible
berries and plants we got blackberries
we got wine berries we got mulberries
so we actually made jam it was amazing
we made some jam without i was having
peanut butter and jelly
and then we're gonna have paw paw we
have tons of apples we made some stuff
with the apples
and uh if people didn't live in cities
and spread out then instead of having
lawns for instance
they could be growing some of their food
and it's self-sustainable and you should
grow some everybody should even if you
only grow like three percent of your
calories the difference between
zero and three percent is night and day
because you know what you learn at three
percent
you're like this is hard and i'm not
that good at it or i have to learn some
stuff or oh tomatoes don't grow with any
shade at all and there's like a lot of
things you gotta learn
the best part is pretty cool i looked up
the nutrition value of mulberries
if you eat 10 mulberries guess how many
calories you get
six yes yes did you look it up no six
we were both wizards six calories
so if you need 2 000 calories per day
you're gonna shake that tree until
there's nothing left on it you burn more
calories shaking the tree yeah we
we grew some zucchinis man these things
grow fast your baseball bats
you don't watch out yeah big ones yeah
they get so uh i saw one and it was
maybe like
five inches long and then i'm like it's
too small the next day it was like
like nine and it's massive and i'm like
i think that's a little too big you know
but what do you just leave them until
they're massive or what well the best
thing is
um you get pigs so my favorite and pigs
love them and they eat them like crazy
so so here's the best part you get pigs
in spring
and in fall is when you're going to be
harvesting them or sending them off to
be harvested and that's when your garden
is like overflowing with stuff you just
can't eat anymore you can't
have another bean you don't want any
more zucchinis the pigs love them
and then all your apples are dropping on
the ground you just give them to them
so so in the winter this is this is the
stuff people really need to think about
you know i can go outside and be like
look at all the fruits and all the
glorious vegetables
and then winter comes around and what
did you say and what did you preserve
right so what do people normally do you
have some chickens and you eat the
chickens in the winter to survive i mean
that's not enough chickens no it really
isn't so potatoes
i mean you have to grow something that
you're going to be able to store for a
long time and you have to think that
through
so this is something this is actually
near and dear to my heart i think people
should be resilient
and being food resilient is part one i
love food resilience i like being energy
resilient as well i can heat my house
four different ways now
what are they um i've got an oil furnace
i've got a wood furnace
i've got um an electrical mini split
and it's a very efficient heat pump that
that
exchanges heat and cool from the outdoor
air very very efficient
oh i was watching a video about these
have you seen that that fluid
that when it when sunlight hits it it
changes the composition
and then they can with an electrical
current electrical current release the
heat energy from it
yeah that's really cool um imagine
warring stuff is going to be that's the
hard part storing energy is always the
hard part
so this is amazing technology imagine
you have
this you have like a a you know
staggered
pipes running with this fluid the
sunlight's hitting it
and then in the winter the sunlight hits
it it changes
it absorbs the energy then goes into
your basement and then converts that
back into heat and heats your home just
from the sunlight being
funneled amazing stuff we should we
should go to superchat what's the fourth
one
you said i got passive so so and this is
just a function of how the thing came we
have this uh stone fireplace that's
probably half the size of this room it's
massive so so it's sort of got like this
it's cool
it's it's warm in the winter cool in the
summer it's like it's just a moderating
influence
it's really good we have uh we have
geothermal here so the copper copper
geothermals awesome yeah it's like
copper tubes run underground
and then we it is extremely efficient
and
it you can get it freezing in here it
was it's a heat wave
and it's like i'm freezing i mean yeah
it's awesome
because the cold underground easily
dissipates the heat and easily pulls in
the cold but
we'll jump over to super chats we'll
jump over search before we do
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and here's the here's the big
thing we are going to
like with steve bannon we had him here
i'm just gonna we're gonna go right for
the most
intense conversation at timcast.com in
the bonus segment because
i realized censorship is getting worse
we needed a place to host our own
content we need a way to sustain it so
we are expanding that whole thing and
now we actually have the opportunity to
have these conversations that youtube is
increasingly shutting down
so make sure you become a member at
timcast.com because that's where you're
going to see the
that's what we're going to talk about
the stuff that we can't hear at least
but we'll
we'll read super chats for now so again
smash that like button all right let's
see what we got here
drizz dress zag says tim can we get a
party slash movement that is against
concentrations of power both government
and corporate
the one we should be the uh the one we
should be freeing is the individual
yes so what what do we call the
decentralization
party yeah that's corporations
consolidating power is bad and
government's doing the same thing is bad
most most systems economic
libertarian centrism centrism if we
could just get the libertarians to get
the
shirts to match the tie and narco
centrist if we can get the libertarians
and the republicans to come together to
create a new party i think we're set
and narco centrists there you go problem
solved people are afraid of anarcho
though
yeah they are libertarian centrists
libero central
yeah we need a gathering for this
decentralized party it's kind of a it's
kind of a wherewit it's tricky
yeah i like the way you think west
virginia country roads man
all right simon verkoe says world war
iii could be fought domestically
global collection of civil wars everyone
just waiting for
china to start first so they can't
backdoor everyone i keep hearing that
china's not nearly as powerful as as
everyone's making them
tiger and that they're also building 100
new nuclear silos is that right and like
the gobi desert or something they're
building all kinds of stuff but but
they're a lot more powerful than people
think
um because they trot out these really
amazing missiles that that they've
gotten
um they've got these missiles that can
reach all over the oceans at this point
in time so so i think
that we're just waiting the next war is
going to be the one that shows that
the navy is just a lot of boats looking
for a reason to sink right
and and we don't want to tangle up with
either russia or china i think that
would be very bad learning because they
we're building these multi tens of
billion dollar like you know aircraft
fleets and they're building these
multi-million dollar missiles that swarm
so so the zircon out of out of russia it
can swarm they can put up dozens of them
and they talk to each other and one
flies up at 100 000 feet if it gets lost
another one volunteers wow
and they come in at six feet off the
deck at mach 5
whoa and then do these crazy 60g
maneuvers to swarm in on something very
hard to stop apparently but we haven't
had to face it so we don't know
mach 1 is the speed of sound correct is
mach 5. five times the speed of sound or
is it
okay yeah and and the problem with that
is even if the warhead doesn't go off
it's got so much kinetic energy it's
like you shot a squirrel with a slug
yeah you know it's just gotta the energy
of the missile alone is a thing
so yeah i don't want to see world war
three i'd really like to avoid that if
we could oh yeah
all right but that's me tactically d
gaming says hey tim shut up from
cheyenne wyoming
just wanted to tell you about my son
cole who watches religiously religiously
with me every day
it's the point i can't watch unless he
is awake he is two years can he get a
shout
tweeted a few pics to you shout out cole
thanks for watching man
get them while they're young good job
cole
douglas kaplan says yesterday you talked
about shadow figures in your room
i have and still experience those do you
think they could be your faults and
guilt that manifested
i'd love to talk more about it and
sometimes i'm terrified of it thoughts
and god bless your group
uh that story was like i was like 13
so i really don't think so i don't think
i had any strong guilts or faults when i
was a little kid
the story was that uh when i was a
little kid i woke up and i could see
like shadow figures walking past my door
and then i tried to just ignore it and
then felt
a presence like i could hear the steps
and i could
it felt like something was walking up to
my bed and then stood there and then
walked away and i was just like a little
kid
so so this person's asking maybe did
those come from inside and you're
thinking
no that's outside yeah no i for all i
know i was a groggy little kid and some
people broke into my house i had that
thought last night when you're talking
about it like did you have emotional
trauma that it was
ex that it was manifesting as like i
feel like something is there
right there's a little kid playing mario
brothers i guess i don't know
i want to chicago huh or maybe you have
a thought and that
these extra-dimensional entities latch
on to that kind of thinking
that's a thing the other the other story
was that one day i was sleeping and i
woke up in the
night rolled over on my left side and
saw the floor
and there looked like there was a
strange waving
energy reflection of light of something
that looked like water being reflected
but
ten times more br like brighter and that
um i
freaked out and i went someone just
suggested that might be intense
moonlight
do you think that was possible no
because i lived in this i lived in
chicago where
you have no like there's no window
that's going to give you a
i mean perhaps perhaps because all the
houses are identical and next to each
other
that the one window like the perfect
angle of moonlight it's entirely
possible and that's why it only happened
one time
that's what i'm saying there's always
some reasonable explanation i'm some
little kid i have no experience or
wisdom and i see something i don't know
and i freak out about it and that's it
but sometimes you see that stuff like i
saw infrared light
you know i saw it when i woke up one day
it was just going into my phone it's
always there
so maybe we could we talk about this on
a
different all right blackrock beacon
says great guest chris was like the
first guy i started following at the
beginning
i started hearing bio stuff started
posting right around the same time as
him
post a lot of this early stuff right on
all right thanks
thanks for that jd says hey tim really
love all of your content
i've been subscribed for over two years
now and recently noticed youtube no
longer gives me notifications when you
start your live show not sure why that
is
i think we're all kind of sure why that
is what happens to me all the time
my subscribers say that a lot and i can
i can track it so when i look at like
when i put a video out
how many come through notifications how
many come through search notifications
is like
under five percent every time now this
is the pressure i was talking about
they don't need to ban us outright but
they exert
pressure on our channel so that over
time attrition destroys them
or they nudge you and you learn oh if i
should maybe not say
things like that right it's a nudging
it's a little nudge we're pretty
obstinate
and so you find people like ethan klein
of h3h3 he used to be super edgy
he would spout racial slurs on his show
now he's
super mainstream because he learned his
lesson and for that he's rewarded with
millions of views on his podcast there
you go
do you have multiple videos a day that
you put up when you don't get
notifications
uh i i put up two a week for sure um in
special weeks get more but but
this notification thing really kicked in
when i started talking about certain
unnamed substances that you can't talk
about okay right and then just notice
that it just it's a form of throttling
someone suggested that you only get
notifications for three videos a day
per channel um i don't know how true it
is but we put up clips so it might be
that you're getting notifications for
the clips and then when the forum
at most we put up one a day but and for
us people say i always got notifications
for the live show and now i don't
all right so um i don't think i can read
the first
name here but uh this guy says come
skate at wakefield tim it's pretty close
to you and we would all love you like 20
of us watched you on joe rogan at once i
just skated in wakefield
last week and i made the joke that
whoever told me to go skate there was
trying to kill me
because the ramps have like uh like the
woods breaking
and they're huge and everything's
falling apart and i'm like
you know this is crazy but we went there
it was it was fun there's a concrete
section which is actually pretty good
but still it's like you know those ramps
dude
yeah maybe you could build it back up
with a gofundme or something apparently
they're renovating it and they're going
to fix it up so
it's a big park it's pretty cool they
just need to fix a lot of stuff and and
the
and the the transitions were super steep
it's fun
there's like a six i think it's a six
foot mini ramp but it's really steep so
you go up and you're like floating right
away it's a very very fast transition
okay cody i see what you're doing here
he says i gotta say something i'm
speechless you know like that book by
michael knowles yeah that's right
like that book from michael knowles i
believe you can get it on amazon
oh shout out to amazon what are other
goods slay the dungeon
says hi tim thanks for inspiring me i
started with youtube thanks to you to
help with culture with dnd
search slay the dungeon i also sent you
an email to your jobs email
i'm a professional dm and pay the bills
with it
i think we're going to need ian to
spearhead that uh that
sure on boarding project i would love to
message me on twitter man
we'll talk dnd yeah so uh the idea is we
would it was a really good idea for a
show
someone super chatted us where we would
basically do scenarios
like once a week someone would write a
dnd scenario someone emailed me saying
you can't do that where it's episodic it
needs to be
continuous oh you can do whatever you
want no but this is a good idea
because we could do a series of 13
episodes where it's
kind of like watching a show where
you've basically got
episode one the introduction to the
story here's the characters
let's play and then everyone's dying to
know what happens by episode 13. did you
ever guys ever read grail quest
the old books they were kind of like you
play as this guy pip who like wakes up
in this body and he's got excalibur jr
this little sword and merlin's like
telling him and it's like an adventure
book that you read and you roll dice
but it was like every every book he
would be in a new world in the same like
body that he would animate
so we could do something like that
rampton says when did you launch the
alpha it still sucks we did not launch
the alpha the new alpha
is missing a ton of things um but we
have the
the it it feels like it's 85 done
and so we're we're aiming for about a
week from now to
hammer out i think the beta might be in
a few days it's awesome
i've i've not seen a website like it
it's it's going to be like a news
website but it also lists individual
channels that we have so
like our youtube channels we're going to
have different shows and podcasts and
then we've got the newsroom with like
trending articles and all that stuff
i am i am mad impressed these these guys
are fantastic at what they're doing
and i'm really excited um because we're
going to have probably like 30 different
shows hopefully within a year or so
um i don't know i don't know how much we
should mention about our conversation
from last night
ben said you know we're working on a
project with that there we go and uh
he's fantastic we'll give you more
details as we go but ben stewart
phenomenal producer i'm really excited
to work and then we're going to be
really cool to hook you up with ben
stewart at some point
cool great we're going to be launching a
new podcast too which may be once a week
and it's the mysteries show so we have
shane cashman who's writing these these
excellent mystery stories the
unexplained paranormal conspiracies just
good good good old spooky spooky fun
times and then we're gonna have
that recorded and we're gonna do a full
episode with like sound effects and like
creaking noises and
footsteps and all the good stuff yeah so
you can really like chill out late at
night during a thunderstorm and just put
it on and be like oh man
and then but but that's only about 15
minutes and then it's gonna go to open
conversation where
you know whoever's hanging out for the
day will be like how did you find this
story and like this is crazy and then
just have an open conversation about the
weird
that'll be so much fun definitely fun
that sounds like fun royce ludwig says
highly suggest getting some beehives at
the cass castle
chicken city and bumble building let's
go
i'm not kidding we got we got such a lot
of grass and there were bees everywhere
and they were chilling
they were i walked over i was picking up
apples the bees were floating around
they're doing their thing i was doing my
thing we're having a good time
speaking about those experts get
yourself a bee expert it's very complex
but oh my god heaven bees is so much fun
they are so cool how they operate it
once you groove on them and just
just however you want to you know settle
in just watch them they are amazing what
they do
we have really chill west virginia wild
honey
and you glaze that bacon with it and
then put it on the grill
something else man it's incredible yeah
yeah honey's legit yeah i had the manuka
honey you ever eat that stuff yeah
the healing properties ian ordered what
like 10 gallons of honey we got it in
the basement
salt and honey and vinegar man that's it
never going to survive we can boil water
and make it hey man that's great
you'll you'll you'll start emaciating to
a certain degree but you'll have honey
you know better than nothing it does
complicate it never spoils they were
they found honey in like ancient
egyptian tombs
that was still edible it crystallizes it
doesn't rot that's amazing yeah it takes
those bees something like two million
flowers that they visit to make a pound
of honey and they go on they they do it
and the single hive might have 50 60
pounds you can harvest
wow it's astonishing and they make your
fruits grow
so you know there's a lot of fruits 2
million flowers
all right trash panda says why is it
that the solutions that elites and greta
tunberg have will kill millions and
wreck everything
instead of pushing for interplanetary
colonization or planting more trees in
nuclear power
i don't know if we can get to
interplanetary colonization fast enough
and i don't even know if it's possible
right a lot of i think i think the mars
stuff is a bit of a pipe dream
well i do too and if you if people are
really excited there is a place in
antarctica you can go
which is about that cold and has about
that much water which is none there's a
dry valley there so just go hang out
there for two weeks tell me how much fun
you're having you still want to go to
mars
doesn't antarctica still have a
magnetosphere to guard you from
solar flares it does it has that this is
kind of awesome too
yeah mars none of that though huh no no
no
it's just it's really cold barren and
dust listen we already have a perfect
spaceship it's here if we can't if you
can't
operate this one you're really going to
hate what happens on mars
that's how i look at it i just heard
that you know that big trench on mars i
mean let's do it but don't don't hope
that that's our like
you know how we're going to save
ourselves i got a double park comment
you know that that
giant trench on mars is huge it's like a
third of the planet or something i
thought it was like a planet collided
with mars and ripped it open and all the
all the magma flew out of the atmosphere
and coated the planet with iron dust and
it rusted now that's why there's always
iron oxide
but apparently it was struck by
electricity mars and venus have been hit
by electrical
and the moon too and that's why there's
all these craters all over the place
there's electrical
you know people don't understand you are
not independent from
the atmosphere and the and the biosphere
and the ecosystems of this earth
the easiest way i think i can explain
how to understand this is
if you've ever played super mario world
you've played it yeah you've played a
great game
mario world no groundbreaking all right
so when you go to the haunted houses
you know how there are those white bars
and the boo ghost will come
out of it and move around and then go
back into it no
you remember that i'm sure a lot of
people know what i'm talking about and
those who don't too bad
but those who do they're gonna go oh you
are connected
to everything on this planet
breathing in the air how the chemical
composition of the air is made by all
the other plant life
what is what is what is soil made of we
walk outside we walk in the soil what is
that made of
billions and billions of organisms um a
little bit of clay a little bit of
carbon a little
organic matter it's all kind of stuff
what you're saying is that when i walk
in my backyard i'm standing on the
corpses of billions of dead creatures
and and uh the live bodies of billions
more that's right
yeah so we emerge from this primordial
muck
before we could even begin to exist
there's tons of
probably more than billions probably
trillions of dead things
that we grow out of and grow our food
from
from clay they say we came from clay the
original people well it's like it's this
fractal thing right so
you take yourself you're a whole thing
you could find out you're a cell you go
down down down down there's just there's
just more and more and more stuff
we can't see it so a single tablespoon
of soil has about as much complexity as
a
maybe a couple dozen square miles of
rainforest now we can imagine rainforest
because you can go and you can see all
the monkeys in the vines it's really
cool and there's ants
but the soil is like that too we just
can't see it except in the alaskan
rainforest where there's no monkeys
no monkeys but they should get them
monkeys i don't think they would last
very long up there
well maybe now i don't know i heard it
was 121 degrees in canada yesterday so
yeah the hottest it's ever been right
yeah two days in a row at least
not by a little bit by a lot wow great
all right check it out
daniel j koreca says wastewater
treatment plant operator here
tim the sewage is treated before it is
discharged into the receiving waters
they don't dump raw sewage
i don't know about chicago and the
surrounding areas because i think
there's a big scandal where they did
and it caused a big problem with e coli
or something well i think i think for
the most part they do and they try but
during heavy rain storms when the when
the plants get
flooded it happens remember when dave
matthews band i think it was drove over
the bridge in chicago
and then the bus driver like or someone
on the bus pulled the release
and sprayed their their their tank onto
a boat underneath
i know there was a boat that's right
they because the
the the the bridges in chicago are
greats so you can look straight down
and i guess the driver was like eh we're
over water pulls it and there was a boat
passing
i'll get sprayed dude yeah for real
save that t-shirt dave matthews man
commander 232 says as someone right
leaning this is what i say to people
about climate change
it is happening but not in the way the
far left screams it is earth doesn't
have a stable climate never has all we
can do is stabilize the gradual change
not run away yeah what do you think
about that uh
entirely possible all i can tell you is
i really enjoyed going growing up during
a period of climate stability
and so i don't call it climate change
anymore i call it climate instability
we're clearly entering a period of
instability
and that's not cool um so if you look at
like climate over time
humans it was the last ten thousand
years has been like really stable on
this chart it's like a flat line
that's when we developed all this stuff
we're like oh this is we'll just do
agriculture because the rains always
fall here
yeah if that changes a lot changes
yeah well we're we are reclaiming vegas
you know
have you ever read about that well i was
out there and i was visiting the guys
who were actually drilling the second
set of pipes down into lake powell
because the first ones were like getting
exposed to air
we gotta go lower right and but i think
they're already in danger of that
effort like they can see the end of that
like it's not gonna last and so what is
vegas worth without water
yes but one thing that is happening is
when we ship in
pepsi and mountain dew and arizona iced
tea
that water comes from other places so
when the food
and the bottled drinks go into vegas and
then people drink it
they then go to the bathroom that water
stays in that area so i was reading
about how there's more clouds now
there's and also i think that's due to
the golf courses you know
no no it probably is yeah absolutely
evapo transporting all that water back
up into the air i know
again the ai machine don't have golf
courses in vegas okay
i i disagree actually so don't do that
the aaa would probably say build golf
courses in vegas
to reclaim more desert allocating water
from areas that have heavy water like
all the rainfall
rainfall on the east coast look at
florida you could take a bunch of that
water from florida and send it somewhere
else it rains non-stop
that's a cool idea but water's heavy
it's so hard it takes so much energy to
move it have you heard
but but think about the ability to uh
expand the biome and grow more life the
sahara for instance
insane how massive it is ai would
probably be like
you get one person to spit and you do
that 50 billion times and you're moving
fluids in water
we are learning how to do agriculture in
different ways so that if you actually
replicate what we had in the plane
structure we have like these massive
grasslands and then you have these
huge herds that come thundering through
you actually create more soil and you
retain more water so we're learning how
we can reclaim desert
by just running our our cows differently
but of course we're going to grow all
our meat in labs now so
have you seen something about that
anymore solar updraft towers
you you have this huge like mile radius
circle of like tarp
and in the middle there's a giant tower
and so the sunlight hits the tarp all
day
though air rushes towards the tower in
the middle and turns these crank
turbines and then goes up the tower
and out and it condenses at night the
water
condenses down and it starts to grow
plant life in the desert
sounds like dune yeah we could build
those all over the place they're they're
out there
all right that's it though zaleski says
hearing tim say dumb mother efforts like
five
times on the bannon members only segment
was worth the ten dollars a month
glad to know youtube might be more lacks
with swearing now pissed him is a best
him
yeah i was i i got mad because i said i
know a bunch of dumb mother efforts
who had no business being involved in
politics all of a sudden coming out
tim's a blue red mage if you've ever
played magic he shows you the blue
when on youtube but he shows you the red
on the after show yeah
when we play magic the gathering so it's
it's like chaos and control combined
so whenever people play games against me
my my mo is always to just like
make the game really strange no one can
do
like i change the rules in weird ways so
the games last for four hours and
everyone's like uh they try to do
something and then it
backfires and then there's one that
turns their spells into doves and they
got a bunch of 1-1 doves for some reason
dove skate by the way anyway carlo big
house says dr chris martinson is an
american hero
chris your video saved lives thank you
for having him on tim
and continuing to share truth and reason
even while the machine struggles to
silence it
you know there's been uh it has gotten a
little bit better in some ways it's
pretty bad
but i remember like two years ago the
censorship was so intense
it was like man i almost had a breakdown
on
several occasions where like a big
breaking news story would come out
and i'd be sitting there looking at it
being like i literally
can't say any of this new york times
story on youtube
and so it'd be really frustrating i'd
try to record and then i'd have to like
not say certain words because youtube
would just nuke you if you did and i'm
like i'm reading the new york times man
and so that eventually i would turn off
the recording and i just be like this is
insane man this is insane i've gotta
do something i got a feeling that
censorship it's not getting worse
necessarily what's happening is it's a
we're it's getting better consistently
but it's
up and down as it constantly goes up
like evolution and like because they
used to kill people for speaking out
against the church like that was the
worst
thing now we're just in a downswing as
it
jolts up and down i think because it's
only been like seven years
or something like that well
we do the same thing at my website where
you know i love
being able to talk to lots of people and
reach them
but i've had to reserve what i actually
think for behind a paywall
um because i got to keep the trolls out
i don't want google sort of sniffing it
and all that other stuff and
i gotta be honest i you're right you got
me i love the truth
i just love it and i don't know what the
truth is but man i can smell bs a mile
away
and i can't talk about that as freely as
i used to and that bothers me
i think it'll come it'll come to a point
where i'm like hey everybody thanks for
joining the show
we're gonna sit here in silence for the
next hour and then we'll go to
timcast.com
no but uh you can't set up a live stream
for the purpose of
moving everybody to a different show so
youtube bans you for that that's weird
yeah like people have made
streams where it's like hey go watch
this stream here on twitch instead and
then youtube shuts the stream down and
bans you for it
so that won't ever come about but it
will be like we're going to do a show
for about 15 minutes what's your
favorite color
blue excellent and uh you uh do you like
arnold palmer's
a drink yeah they're good mm-hmm can we
just meditate and then we'll do it in
12 minutes no but thank you tim
do you like my glasses all right all
right um
brie anna says tim i would like to know
your opinion on john mcafee
and whacked as well as uh as the reason
why several big names in online
communities are censoring anything
related to it what's going on i honestly
don't know
i i did a video segment about it where
his wife came out saying she didn't
think he took his own life and he wasn't
suicidal or anything like that
i don't know um i've heard a lot of
speculation but nothing i can really say
you know there's like apparently some
crypto ethereum started moving around or
something or like
like really small amounts they think
they're nfts no idea i honestly don't
know
yeah i haven't seen anything about it
really nothing to get your arms around
woody says just wanted to mention
something about that vitamin c stuff
i looked into carnivore dieting a few
years ago and there was information i
discovered showing that we don't absorb
as much vitamin c because it competes
for the same receptors as carbs any
thoughts on this
do you know anything about that no i
haven't heard about that one but it it
kind of makes sense so
scurvy was a big thing right it was
awful your teeth would fall out
is really bad um so getting getting that
vitamin c back in was really really
important
um most of that as far as i'm aware not
coming from meats itself it's coming
from you know obviously certain types of
fruits and vegetables things like that
but this is uh this is a big one
actually andrea says so cuomo's shutdown
of indian point nuclear power plant was
finalized in april 2021
that plant provided 81 percent of new
york's clean energy output
it also provided 19 to 25 percent of new
york's and surrounding areas total power
cuomo promised nyc would be okay without
it who would have guessed
yeah they had they had power shutdown
that was failing it's just magic
you just plug your plug into other
outlet on the wall and it just shows up
it's just it's ridiculous
how silly that is we need these new
plants badly
i was talking to an activist once and
this was the craziest thing to me i was
explaining how nuclear power is clean
energy
that sure we should make sure it's safe
no meltdowns thorium salts a big thing
whatever
and the response was we don't need any
of that just plug your
your your computer into the wall and i
was like
right well sure but we're talking about
coal power plants yeah we don't need any
of those like the ac
it's like in the wall i'm not kidding
that was an actual conversation
they had to be joking no it's like the
milk on the shelf yeah oh my gosh
and i was like you you know that there
are like wires back there
and it all connects to like the grid
and there's a place where they store and
produce it
and they were like no it's just i
thought it was just like there
wow yeah no that's uh we we have we have
some big things to work on
but i i actually would would be i would
sign up not for these big boiling water
new plants like they have at indian
point all that other stuff forget that
these little pebble bed reactors you
know we have the voyager spacecraft is
out there taking pictures from billions
of miles away it's got a little nuke
plant on it right these things are yeah
what what are they they're they're
they're just a way of they
they take the heat and they convert it
more directly into electricity you don't
have to boil water so there's little
pebble bed reactors and things like that
and they can fit in the size of
a storage container what does it do it
literally takes the energy that's coming
out of the nuclear fission process
that creates a lot of heat and it takes
the heat and it converts it into
electricity through either a
thermoelectric process or some other
process right where it's
just taking that energy and converting
it more directly
right so you could set these things up
and it would power like 500 600 homes
in a neighborhood right and it would
last for decades is it also uranium
that is uranium but i do like you
mentioned thorium i like the lifters a
lot i think we should invest in that
technology
right on we'll probably be buying it
from china though because they're
working on it or not
we're going to do we're going to do one
more because we really want to get to
that member segment so stephen orr says
shout from akron children's hospital
keep the convo flowing i listen in the
am takes my mind off my situation
my son was born three months early now
he is six months old and has chronic
lung uh chronic issues wizard
crossland my friend i was born in akron
general
my my father used to work there as an
orthopedic technician that's my nine
months early right
that's what i heard i was born nine
months early on demand
he emerged from a rift in the time space
continuum as you see him now
my mother my father meditated and i was
born
from the ether and like as his his being
was being formed
ian's mom was like we need more power
and the dad was like it's not enough i'm
losing it don't give him like the other
three scientists like got blown back
it's crazy and then
really gaunt with long fingers and he
had gray scaly skin and he was like what
am i earth is and they're like a quick
quick hold him down and he was
thrashing and screaming and then they
gave him shrooms and then he started to
change back to where he is now
now you see him as he is i've asked him
like five times not to tell that
it checks out though doesn't it okay
everybody
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel more importantly go to
timcast.com become a member we will have
that that members only segment up
uh hopefully around 11 but it might go
long because it's going to get intense
and uh you can follow the show at tim
cast irl on facebook instagram basically
wherever else
and um we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm so we will be
back tomorrow and you can follow me
personally at timcast do you want to
shout out your
channels or anything sure you can find
me at peakprosperity.com that's my
big old website there got a great team
helping me run that and
check out chris martinson
m-a-r-t-e-n-s-o-n at youtube
at chrismartinson on twitter all over
the place you do subscriptions on
peakprosperity.com we do we have
subscriptions we got a paywall and and
we go deep so
anybody wants to actually follow where
the data is going and and
we got a great community of people
really smart really curious
someone said ian is a homunculus
what's the name of the yeah yeah you got
to play magic
to get it i guess what is that he's like
a little uh one-eyed homunculus yeah
homunculus is an artificial creature
created by
artificial human made by alchemists you
know me so well
so your parents were alchemists they
manifested you oh yeah yeah my dad was
in the navy
[Laughter]
y'all can follow me at ian crossland.net
and at ian crossland on all social media
thank you for coming did you guys notice
the sword behind ian
oh yeah it's this is uh links master
sword is it not
the master circle you can see part of it
this is the triforce embedded in the
we're gonna we're
we're moving the studio they're
beginning construction tomorrow man i'm
still
nice yeah so it's uh same building just
the the seat the table's gonna be
attached to the ceiling at the floor
nice yeah we're going crazy nice yeah
i'd love to hear it
you deserve it and i'm also in the
corner i was gonna say ian's parents
were trying to make gold and they came
up with ian which i would say is a
pretty good
exchange you guys can follow me at
sourpatchlids on twitter as i attempt to
gain more followers and sour patch kids
go to timcast.com become a member
the episode will be up at some point
tonight it may go long
and we'll see you all there bye guys
you